раз два раз
який має назву колить у нього і Сьогодні
ми з вами будемо обмінювати
тому напрямку як вже покращити
професійну освіту як зробити так щоб
Кажуть все одно
Зараз ми будемо
А ви бачили на
ні ні
Ага отак стало краще
отут стояти ага
ні і тут
в принципі
[музика]
Олена Колеснікова голова комітету
сталого розвитку федерації роботодавців
України
Геннадій русанов експерт з питань
професійної освіти польського фонду
міжнародної солідарності Марина
Попатенко радниця з питань політик та
залучення програми мріємо та діємо
айрекс Україна
Юрій Баланюк
Голова Національного агентства
кваліфікації і наша Я сподіваюсь вже
нова бо вона знаєте професійну освіту
коли потрапляєш
керівниця клубу добродій ініціаторка
дослідження підлітки та їхні життя під
час війни настрої цінності майбутнього
Отже сьогоднішня Тема нашої першої
панельної дискусії це професії необхідні
для відновлення країни і як зробити їх
популярними і оскільки спікери довільно
обирали собі місце то я думаю що ми так
і почнемо думала починати з тої частини
того власне так свою ідею і продовжу
хочу зараз дати слово пану телісу
олійнику заступнику директора державного
центру зайнятості ДНЗ у нас до вас
просте питання ви як центр зайнятості
працюєте з тими хто Втратив роботу або
потребує зміни роботи ми розуміємо
наскільки міграційні процеси спричинені
війною вплинули загалом на структуру
зайнятості в Україні і у нас до вас
зрозуміли питання А як ви бачите який
основні тенденції сьогодні на ринку
праці що вже є і наявне сьогодні І чого
очікувати у майбутньому Давайте я вам
дам все ж таки свій мікрофон щоб було
вже надійніше
Вітаю Шановні колеги
дивіться така ситуація що коли вина
задала таких нам величезних збитків вона
змінила і структуру попитного
працівників і суттєво змінила ситуацію
зареєстрованих безробітних зараз на
обліку майже 72% це жінки і 28% це
чоловіків
Але в цьому роботодавці
потребують зараз дуже кваліфікованих
працівників переважної в більшості це
робоча професії такий там водії
Трактористи слюсари механіки ремонтніки
електрогазозварники
і роботодавці не хочуть чекати вони
хочуть отримати
швидко зараз сьогодні
про працівника
і
нами Разом з партнерами в січні лютому
було проведено опитування Ми просили
майже вісім тисяч підприємців
було проведено
фокус груп
експертів був такий зроблений тотальний
аналіз ринку праці і потреби і ми
визначили що більш всього потребують
опять же це робочі спеціальності це
водії ремонтники
медсестри автоматери тощо Ми постійно
аналізуємо ринок праці трансформуємось
під нього
і тому я хотів би зупинитись більш
детально на наші такі сучасні і
популярні програми яку ми вже
запровадили це програма ваучернонавчання
в цьому році відповідно до потреб і
виклику економіки України нам була
запроваджена ця програма вірніше
Ця програма трошки трансформувалась да і
зараз перелік налічує 123 професій
зроблено
онлайн-додаток він себе скажемо так
зарекомендував і показав Дуже якісно
після опитування більше 200 осіб
ми от разом з міністерством освіти
отримали по 10-бальній шкалі
9,9 задоволених відповідей на
користування цього додатку скористалися
вже 11 з половиною тисяч осіб ми Видали
ваучери на навчання більше там 51
мільйона гривень
постійно
трансформуємось ми разом з змін
економіки і мінус освіти намагаємося
бути сучасними додавати професії які
потребують цей перелік і дуже плідно
працюємо закладами освіти тому що
повністю трансформована видача цього
ваучеру Після онлайн заявки протягом
трьох днів наш фахівець вже зв'язується
з потенціальним клієнтом обирає заклад
освіти таке інше Це робиться дуже-дуже
швидко
тому сподіваюсь що такими власними
зусиллями ми наближемо нашу перемогу і
відбудуємо Україну дуже дякую Вам слава
Україні
Дякую Дениса шановні спікери ми
перепрошуємо ми зараз вам теж принесемо
навушнички кому не вистачило бо
зрозуміли що технічно це є необхідним
дуже цікаві у вас цікава була інформація
особливо в частині того що наприклад на
сьогодні безробіття в нас стало жіночим
Та ну тобто воно змінилось кардинально і
звичайно цікавими є програми якими ми
користуємося і які є успішно Я думаю
реалізуємо в системі професійної освіти
це навчання за ваучерами зрозуміло що
зміна на ринку праці буде вимагати
можливо нових механізмів і
нової підтримки безробітніх А в мене
питання до пані Олени я точно знаю що
Федерація роботодавців активно бере
участь у різноманітних дослідженнях
ринку праці проводить самостійно
дослідження і яка думка на сьогодні
роботодавців з приводу нашого головного
питання яких потребує ринок праці
фахівців сьогодні і яких буде
потребувати
в процесі відновлення і як взагалі
роботодавці чи готуються роботодавці для
того щоб
змінюватися
Я по-перше хочу щоб ви склали
конкуренцію залу справу і залу зліва бо
вони аплодували комусь за спікерів А в
нас вже перший виступи вибрав мовчали
Дякую
Дуже я мені обіцяли що презентація в
мене буде запускатися да
що просто по презентацію якщо можна так
якщо можна презентації
з'явилась на екрані презентація Ми не
домовлялися з Денисом якщо щось але я
продовжу то прошу почали вже говорити я
продовжу про те як змінюється в нас і
якраз про зайнятість жінок
статистику ми не завжди проводимо всі
дослідження Федерації роботодавця самі
ми часто користуємося дослідженнями які
вже проводилися Ми беремо дані
аналізуємо так само і співпрацюємо ми
дійсно так само бачимо ситуацію як
змінюється в нас гендерно але я завжди
наводжу приклад коли мені кажуть що от
жінку десь там наприклад от в
металургієва замало жінок да от Чому
вони не стають генеральними директорами
Я кажу давайте подивимося хто йде
вчитись на технічні спеціальності там
більшість хлопців якщо більшість хлопців
то яка статистична взагалі вибірка буде
жінок вона звичайно буде менше тому не
тому що їх не пускають наприклад
технічні Тому що жінки не обирають
технічні професії і експеримент
наприклад
про моя колега
Марина дітей а достатньо малого віку в
школі намалювать професії наприклад
пожежника або лікаря або
поліцейського всі діти намалювали
чоловіків і вони для
В цій професії коли вони їх завели до
класу і показали що може бути жінка
лікарем жінка може бути пожежником в
дітей був стрес вони не розумі
ли це жінка чому поліцейські це жінка і
чому пожежник може бути теж жінкою але
це стосується не тільки дітей насправді
коли ми бачимо статистику хто вступає на
професію в нас Я думаю що ви всі точно
знаєте про наші змагання воротків Я
кожного разу радію коли в електриках
наприклад дівчинка я стою біля неї я так
хлопаю мені так хочеться щоб вона щось
виграла бо вона одна дівчинка серед всіх
хлопців і не побоялися приймати брати
участь
ми дорослі з вами боїмося змінювати свої
стереотипи На жаль а ринок праці і
воєнний і післявоєнний буде цього
вимагають ну такі в нас вже обставини і
тому коли ми дивимося Ми всі знаємо з
вами що була постанова постанова
Кабінету Міністрів яка багато років
забороняла багато професій для жінок То
може для когось це стане новина її
відмінили років Шість тому десь
приблизно а жінок не побільшало професія
тому по-перше я звертаюсь до жінок Ми ж
не можемо якийсь У нас є дуже круті
чоловіки Вибачайте мене за правду але ну
така правда коли на одному з підприємств
Дякую
посадили на складні гірничі машини жінок
бо там більше зарплата краще умови і так
далі але раніше до того часу було
заборонено жінку і жінки почали ходити
ці кар'єрні машини аварії стало менше
поломак стало менше топливо стало більше
і компанія так подумала Я сказав Ми
навіть не очікували на такі результати
Тому у цій стереотипи в нас живуть
постійно їх треба змінювати час на
змінюю вимоги часу змінюють все що може
бути зараз у нас компанія не буде я
просто так миную назви компаній щоб не
видавати секрети думаю про то як
перефарбувати в рожевий теж великі
машини які їздять
щоб жінці цікавіше їде щоб всі бачили що
там жінка водій бо це складні машини на
сьогодні у нас там ще немає жінок в цій
компанії на цих посадах але через того
що чоловік їмо всі знаємо де вони нас
всіх захищають зараз разом з жінками але
статистично чоловіків більше центр
зайнятості так само підтвердився цифри
назвав то кожна компанія думає яким же
чином який танці був Нам треба зробити
щоб жінка захотіла стати на ту професію
здобути якою раніше навіть не думала що
там може бути жінка як оті діти в школі
Так коли малюють тільки чоловіки тому
Таким чином ми в мене презентація колись
ділась
[музика]
співробітники що можна повернуть
презентацію
Я пам'ятаю за презентацію в нас
наступний слайд іде це наступний виклик
який про жінок ми проговорили це
інклюзія раніше коли ми з вами говорили
про інклюзію більшість випадків як
роботодавців нас йшла дискусія про те
яка квота працевлаштувати Да з інклюзією
людей і так далі зараз ми розуміємо що
це наше нове життя і кількість людей які
постраждали від військової агресії
Російської їх Ну я навіть не знаю такого
слова яке б описала взагалі всі відчуття
які ми з вами зараз переживаємо але ми
розуміємо що це не тільки інклюзія
фізична це ще психологічна і дуже сильна
насправді і зараз вже кожен роботодавець
думає яким чином як нам інтегрувати всіх
цих людей в цивільне життя Ми
співпрацюємо з багатьох з багатьма
нашими партнерами в тому числі з юроюком
стосовно того як визнавати наприклад
військові спеціальності в цивільному
житті да Якщо він ремонтував там
він може ремонтувати тут для того щоб і
не здобувати щось таке Чого немає Нікому
не потрібно і йому було простіше бо він
вже вважає себе спеціалістом гарним і
так далі затребуваним щоб йому було
комфортніше цієї людини але на сьогодні
чесно вам скажу в жодному бізнесі немає
відповіді Скільки і як і є купа професії
на жаль я завжди наводжу приклад бо в
нас є закон е-е так само про людей з
інвалідністю де треба там обов'язково
мати для того щоб навчати пандуси і так
далі але є такі професії як
високовольтне це неможливо фізично
замінити людину яка повинна збиратися на
верхівку тобто просто неможливо І тому
ми зараз для себе намагаємося зрозуміти
яке це може бути робоче місце що ми
можемо зробити якком кожна компанія для
того щоб дати це і найголовніше ще раз
кажу коли ми кажемо про інклюзії ми
часто забиваємо про психологічний стан
людей і це не тільки військові так само
цивільні які пережили страшні Ну я ж
кажу страшні переживання про які навіть
не можна говорити бо емоції просто за і
тому для нас це дуже великий як для
ринку праці і ми так само в нашій
професії в навчання ми вже закладаємо ну
наприклад як спілкуватися з людиною яка
прийшла та яка має якісь вади так
здорові своєму що казати чи допомагати
їй чи вона повинна сама справлятися В
мене є гарна знайома Оля Руднєва вона
постійно пише блоги про то в Фейсбуці як
вони працюють це Human Боже я забула як
правильно називається
Да Супер Human центр та де вони
займаються реабілітацією я постійно коли
я дивлюся скільки вона робить і як вона
описує відчуття тих людей які вже
проходять цей етап до такого більш
цивільного життя які виклики стоять Я
навіть не уявляю скільки ще викликів
буде попереду коли ці люди будуть йти на
робочі місця як з одного боку зі сторони
бізнесу зі сторони кожної колеги Да і
колег які будуть
співпрацювати наш один з найголовніших
викликів далі
хоч і війна але в нас в країну ніхто не
зупиняє і європейські колеги так само
кожного дня планують якусь ще нову
екологічну ініціативу А ми все одно не
дивлячись на війну рухаємося за ними І
це так само то про що ми на сьогодні
насправді в нас професійні освіти цього
поки немає розуміння до кінця але
стандарти Європейського Союзу
екологічної на сьогодні на підприємстві
вже починають багато де виконуватись і
через то нам треба інтегрувати тепер те
що є на підприємствах навчальні програми
тому що про екологію ми завжди дуже мало
говорили колеги це було так само не
популярно як і технічні професії багато
років ти куди пішов на екологію чи
дурний типу нема що робити бо на
екологію пишу а зараз Всі розуміють що
без цього ми не зможемо експортувати
свою продукцію якщо ми зможемо
експортувати свою продукцію ми не
зможемо заробляти валюту а відповідно в
нас в країні починається економічні
проблеми тому кожна компанія дбає про те
дивиться що відбувається в Європейському
Союзі які зміни відбулися яким чином
повинна і кожен співробітник на
підприємств
зараз відбувається і чому ми це робимо
чому потрібні ці зміни а для того це теж
треба Потрібно інтегрувати саме в
освітні програми готувати навіть зі
школи починати про це більше говорити
для розуміння тому що мене наприклад
завжди задіває трохи Що Чому вони нам
кажуть коли нас набагато розумніші люди
і вони можуть щось зробити своє так а ми
повинні купляти наприклад їх обладнання
бо воно екологічне а наше - ні І тому ми
тут з одного боку ми хочемо підтримати
українського виробника з іншого боку ми
не завжди розуміємо А що це таке бо ми
трошки не довчилися і
тому екологія це теж
дуже Ну і звичайно
Дмитра з нами немає але ми про нього
говоримо він завжди з вами він
долучиться цифровий перехід коли я ди
влюся все що їм треба на телефоні в
Ютубі все що вони хочуть подивитися
йому від них Тобто я не знаю як вчить
дітей але нас дорослих вчить треба
використовувати цифрові технології тут
напевно десь 70% більшості виробництва
Яке зараз є в Україні але знаєте в чому
проблема тоді на 70% прийдеться
скоротити наших співробітників А якщо це
місто утворюючи підприємства якщо 70%
звільнюється ми розуміємо соціальний
вибух який відбувається Тому цього не
можна робити і
без тірамі між повною автоматизацією
цифровізації між тим щоб зберегти
максимально своїх людей на робочих
місцях бо це можуть бути місто утворюючі
підприємства це дуже важливо для міста
бо це податки всі з кожної людини яка
працює і так далі зайнятість людей Тому
ми насправді коли говоримо про виклики
Та тут немає ми не хотіли багато слайдів
одного виклику - це швидке перенавчання
ми працюємо разом зараз з міністерством
над змінами в законодавстві для того щоб
вам були закладам професійно-технічної
освіти можна було швидко перенавчати
тому що це один з найголовніших викликів
Ми багато через ту саму цифровізацію
автоматизацію багато робочих місць вони
просто не актуальні декілька років тому
вони наприклад доказували цілими
міністерству тоді ще соціальної політики
що Ну немає вже низьких розрядів ну не
можна знайти робоче місце де другий
розряд Ну немає їх більше все вони вже
ви Вони починаються в найкращому випадку
з третього А той з четвертого з п'ятого
чому Тому що вийшла
автоматизм не тільки освітні да а і
трудове законодавство і багато чого і ми
зараз над
ними зібачити що
можемо швидко отримати
нову перекваліфікувати себе нічого в
тому поганого і складно скільки б тобі
років не було бо я завжди знову ж таки
наводжу один приклад і мені дуже
подобається коли я пам'ятаєте весь
інтернет Дуді е-е
83 роки Якщо я не помиляюся а-а бабулька
така дуже хороша вступила якщо я знову ж
таки не помиляюся в Гарвард і всі
дивилися і казали ну як а вона каже бо
прийшов час тому я вам всім бажаю
прийшов час змін ми всі змінюємося в нас
немає іншого вибору і ми переможемо
точно у всіх наших викликах які є бо ми
є українці дякую Дуже дякую Олено ми
виправляємось дякую публіку власне Якщо
говорити про коротку термінове навчання
це дійсно один із тих трендів який
сьогодні з'являється І він з'являється
не просто так як освітній тренд або як
тренд на ринку праці він спричинений
певними подіями Які в нас відбуваються
але якщо повертатися знову ж таки до
того А який фахівці А скільки цих
фахівців Сьогодні має бути на ринку
праці може працювати на економіку
України ми все ж таки звертаємося до
певних досліджень до отримання таких
валідних даних і я зараз хочу передати
слово Геннадію який власне є керівником
спочатку і Frost Hills зараз вже
окремого компоненту зараз вже іншого Ми
сподіваємося проекту власне діяльність
якого була зосереджена наприклад не
тільки на аналізу ринку праці а на зміні
підходів профорієнтації тобто поєднання
це переходу від потреб ринку праці до
того А як ми
заохочуємо молодь заохочуємо доросле
населення наприклад до перенавчання до
здобуття нової професії Геннадію вам
слово
багато людей я дуже-дуже коротко спробую
укреслити власне ну питання які професії
Нам потрібні насправді проста відповідь
всі тому що людей стає менше
економіку треба піднімати і дефіцит
робітничих кадрів
є вже дуже-дуже давно Як не дивно я
скажу можливо доволі дивну річ але війна
і війна довша яка вона вже триває багато
років і широкомасштабне вторгнення не
змінили тенденції на ринку праці Вони
просто їх пришвидшили в дуже-дуже-дуже
багато разів в нас була погана
демографічна ситуація зараз вона
радикально погіршилась в нас був дефіцит
робітничі кадрів як показували наші
дослідження вже протягом кількох років
цей дефіцит радикально збільшився в нас
була проблема з інклюзивністю ринку
праці доступністю людей з
інвалідністю чи людей з ментальними
проблемами
до ринку праці ця проблема збільшилась в
мільйона разів тому що ми всі маємо
зараз проблеми такі в нас була проблема
з доступністю жінок до деяких професій
ця проблема І ще більше і ще збільшилась
тому насправді війна просто дуже сильно
збільшила ці всі тенденції оголила ці
проблеми і ми дійсно мусимо на ці
проблеми знаходити відповіді тому що
якщо ці відповіді не будуть знайдені
наша економіка просто впаде
це такі Можливо трошки погано Зараз До
хорошого насправді українська професійне
освіта і освіта вже довший час дуже
добре адаптується до таких викликів
і Я відійду від професій що насправді
нам потрібно коли ми опитували
роботодавців вже протягом кількох років
то крім того що ми запитували про
професії і очевидно тут дійсно потрібні
те що говорив пан Донецьку що говорила
що нам потрібні робітничі професії це
металообробка це зварювання це електрики
Тобто це те що заставляє інфраструктуру
України працювати те що те що поки що не
заміниш ні штучним інтелектом ні
машинами або навіть якщо замінить з
машинами туди них теж потрібні люди але
насправді такі наскрізною
ниткою є те що ми називаємо м'які
навички Тобто це те чого вимагають
роботодавці
ми останній опитування які ми проводили
спільно з колегами із Федерації з служби
зайнятості це робота в команді це вміння
приймати рішення це стресостійкість цей
знання іноземних мов і так далі тобто я
можу перелючувати ці навички в нас є
дуже багато інформації але це той
фундамент який дозволяє людям гнучко
змінювати професію тому що вони
змінюються дуже-дуже гнучко дуже швидко
і якщо ми будемо виховувати
з початкової фактично школи з дитячого
садочкою дальше вище зеленком освіти у
цій якості то Ми створимо
фахівців Ми створимо учнів які зможуть
добре робити цей вибір робити його
інформовано і робити правильно
що для цього треба зробити Насправді те
про що говорила пані Ірена
профорієнтація в нас традиційно
зводилось і зводиться досить пір до
тестування Тобто ми проводимо якісь
тести тестуємо дитину І кажемо що в неї
є нахили до не знаю малювання чи до
токарної справи Чи чогось іншого це ну
не дуже ефективно не дуже працює
насправді
в Україні треба і це те що ми почали
робити теж треба створювати систему
інформування орієнтації молоді і
дорослих так само Бо ми дуже часто коли
говоримо про освіту говоримо про молодь
чи про дітей ні освіта - це всі і
дорослого очевидно більше і треба їх теж
перевчати А якщо ми говоримо про
свідомий вибір дітей вже то насправді ми
повинні з садочку з початкової школи
вводити ці елементи профорієнтації
інформувати дітей інформатив викладачів
давати їм інструменти для того щоб все
це інтегрувати в стандарти освіти
навчальні програми за різними предметами
це те чого не вистачається величезний
величезний шмат роботи тому що освіта
річ інерційна Тобто ми діти не ростуть
швидше ніж ви не ростуть і вони не
навчаються швидше ніж це фізично можливо
і тому щоб ми мали
тих фахівців які ми хочемо яких ми
хочемо які потрібні економіці Ми повинні
вже зараз про це думати Це означає що
треба вносити зміни в освітні стандарти
треба інтегрувати елементи
профорієнтації в кожен кожен компонент
кожен предмет треба як на мене вводити
інститут кар'єрних радників чи про в
школах чи навчати системно викладачів в
цьому тому що на жаль педагоги масово в
основному орієнтують дітей на вищу
освіту і це не питання кут що вища
освіта погана Ну вона в цілому не дуже
хороша але це
колеги звички не ображається але
ось
Але тим не менше Ми повинні давати
інформовані вибір що можливостей є
багато і вони не обмежені вищою освітою
чи професійною освітою вони просто є
необмежені і педагоги повинні давати
дітям і дорослим теж розуміння того що
насправді цих можливостей дуже-дуже
багато можливостей для заробітку
можливості для реалізації себе
це не означає що тому що мусиш бути
менеджером і працювати в офісі
цього На жаль немає І це треба вже
починати робити дуже-дуже системно все
треба інвестувати не тільки гроші але й
дуже-дуже багато часу і перш за все
навчати цьому викладачів педагогів
оскільки вони будуть основними носіями
інформації Ну так дуже коротко Ніби все
дякую
я себе Тепер я вже себе чую Дякую
Геннадію Дякую колеги за підтримку
власне в вас завжди коли слухаєш
розумієш що знову ж таки ми навчаємо
мабуть не тому і не так як треба просто
скіли ми всі розуміємо наскільки це
важливо і ми наче купу тренінгів для
педагогів з цих питань проводимо але
весь час розуміємо що недостатньо от щоб
зробити для того щоб було достатньо Ми
якраз поговоримо ще на третій панелі
сьогодні сподіваюсь це теж допоможе а
зараз я передаю слово пані Марині і
Марина ми не хотіли від вас дізнатися Я
знаю що ви сьогодні представляєте
організацію яка дуже активний багато
підтримує Україну в частині
запровадження такої системної
професійної орієнтації Я знаю що теж
маєте персональний досвід
подібних заходів і роботи з молоддю на
вашу думку ви сьогодні більше з освітою
працюєте Що ми робимо Не так та і і
що нам потрібно змінити І як ви нас
обіцяєте з цих питаннях підтримати
вони роблять щось не так мені здається
Зараз ми всі трансформуємося і про це ми
чули сьогодні на першій панелі І власне
на мій особистий погляд освіта це ключ
до всього в першу чергу це ключ до
розвитку країни і безумовно освіта і де
завжди поряд з розвитком економіки і
сьогодні
в рамках того проекту який представляю
програма мрії мотодіє має всі країни є б
хотіла більше розказати про ту
діяльність яку ми проводимо з молоддю з
дітьми і власне в напрямку освіти для
нас що мені дадуть клікер Я навіть
переключу
Дякую
звісно ми свою роботу
базуємо на дослідженні і на даних які
збираємо і відповідно для нас також
важливо вкладати ефективно наші ресурси
і ми робили дослідження разом з нашими
партнерами центром корпоратива
соціальної відповідальності які пройдуть
сьогодні вже згадували І власне що ми
побачили ми побачили що
перспективі про що говорять сьогодні всі
панелісти Україні буде десь 10 галузі
роботи в яких буде ще довго довга
актуальна після перемоги і відповідно
зосереджуємо свою діяльність зараз на
тому щоб молодь діти робили
поінформований вибір і власне
хотіли йти навчатися саме на ті
спеціальності які будуть потрібні
Україні для її подальшого трансформації
розвитку і відновлення і очевидно що для
того щоб ця робота здійснювалася дуже
активно ми маємо побудувати системні
рішення і я не буду перераховувати всю
всі ці професії ви за qr-кодом можете
подивитися взагалі на все аналітику яка
робиться
щодо ринку праці і відповідно для нас
дуже важливо побудувати системний підхід
і системне рішення Тому вже дуже давно
напрацьовується робота щодо
побудови мережі кар'єрних центрів І
власне те що для нас важливо
наші партнери центр національної
відповідальності мають модель кар'єру
орієнтованої школи мають вже асоціацію
кар'єрних радників мають вже багато
напрацьованих матеріалів для того щоб
ефективно і якісно розвивалася центр
кар'єри якщо говорити з позиції
молодіжної роботи то тут має бути просто
відкритий підхід до роботи з дитиною до
роботи з молодою людиною і відповідно
всі ці ворк щодо навчання спеціалістів
які напрацьовуються вони якраз дають
можливість зрозуміти ті підходи щоб бути
зрозумілим безпосередньо користувачу щоб
поєднувати запити ринки ринку праці в
першу чергу з безпосереднім бенефіціаром
тобто з нашим майбутнім бутирінтом і
відповідно нам Дуже хотілось би щоб
центр кар'єри в закладах освіти
трансформувалися і була єдина
єдиний системний підхід тому в
наступному році
ми зосереджуємо свою увагу разом з
міністерством освіти на побудові такої
єдиної моделі від школи до переходу до
студенства до дорослих людини саме в
кар'єрному консультуванні і
профорієнтації тому що коли ми говоримо
про і тут дуже важливо теж розуміти ці
поняття що коли ми говоримо про
профорієнтаційну роботу ми маємо
працювати як з дитиною Так і обов'язково
з батьками Тобто ми маємо працювати з
аудиторіями тому що якщо знову ж таки
дивитись на дослідження більше дуже
велика кількість молодих людей робить
неусвідомлений вибір тому що на нього
впливають батьки і тут я хотіла
наголосити на ще деякі дані зараз за ще
одними нашими цікавими дослідженнями ми
побачили що дуже багато батьків
розуміють і усвідомлюють які професії
будуть а необхідні для відновлення
країни але не хочуть щоб їх діти йшли на
цій професії І власне тут на слайді ви
можете побачити що ми в наступному році
будемо Ну вже скоро будемо починати
працювати над команський комунікаційною
компанією ми обрали поки що чотири
напрямки професії три ви можете побачити
на слайді четвертий ми ще обираємо з
міністерством освіти науки і хочемо
працювати саме з батьками для того щоб
переконувати і інформувати батьків що їх
діти будуть більш перспективному
розвитку якщо вони підуть навчатись саме
на цій професії які будуть актуальні і
можна Їх діти будуть напевно більш
щасливі якщо вони зроблять
поінформований вибір і про те Сьогодні
ми чули на попередній панелі про кого
говорив п Федоров про це говорив пан
Федоров І власне друге - це створення
моделі кар'єрно-орієнтованого підходу в
освіті А нам дуже хочеться щоб
різноманіття різно підходів і моделей
які є в Україні які робить і ufus Kills
які робиться державним центром
зайнятості які робляться абсолютно
іншими стейколдерами
не працювали розрізнено і ми перестали
постійно пілотувати різноманітні
підходів а сіли за стіл і власне
спільно напрацювали комплексне рішення
як має вестися профорієнтаційна робота
Кар'єрна консультування в Україні єдина
комплексне рішення за які можуть
працювати і заклади професійно-технічної
освіти і передвищу освіти і власне школа
і вищий навчальний заклад І таким чином
ми зможемо мати
якісно якісну роботу і кар'єрних
радників і таким чином ми зможемо мати
методологічну базу для постійного
підвищення кваліфікації кар'єрних
радників цього Також ми дуже хотіли би
змінити власне і
професійний стандарт кар'єрних радників
тому що він давно потребує оновлення і
на цьому теж зосередимося в наступному
році Разом з нашими партнерами і
міністерствами освіти науки Дякую Дякую
Марина власне ви бачите як Багато в нас
планів аплодисменти
А я от інколи люблю задавати
провокативні питання не тільки спікерам
а і нашим учасникам дискусії які
перебувають в аудиторії по-перше це я
бачу що тут є керівники закладів і точно
знають що є методисти
і про центр корпоративної соціальної
відповідальності брав участь у їхніх
проєктах попередніх можна підняти руку
ага ага
Ніна Миколаївна точно знає що ви
працювали але ви рікою не піднімаєте і
тут у мене вже питання погано чуєте так
теж брали участь Тобто так а тепер
наступне питання Те що затронула Марина
про вибір свідомий вибір професії Там ми
розуміємо що ми хочемо щоб буде дитина
далі людина у своїй 14-15 років обрала
професі
ю я буду обирати одну професію
і обрали собі професію один раз на все
життя от Як ви вибрали у 19 років Так ви
продовжили ось Ну я би сказала що це
якраз яскравий свідчення того що ми ну
змінюються потреби ринку праці
змінюються умови роботи
змінюється наші уподобання так
розвиваємося і готові переходити на інші
етапи і якраз те про що емоційний
операційної спільно з проектом і не
тільки професійне
професійно орієнтація а ще й кар'єрний
консультування це якраз тести навички
які дуже потрібні на сьогодні кожного
українця для того щоб бути успішно
реалізованим на ринку праці А зараз я
хочу передати слово Юрію баланюку більше
того додам що в нього ще є одна Ну от
важлива місія цього року в нас Юрій
координатор національної європейського
руху навичок в Україні і ми вже окремі
заходи провели цієї весни але теж
сподіваємося разом з вами багато чого
реалізувати
починаючи з нового навчального року але
сьогодні ми хочемо попросити Юрія все ж
таки поговорити можливо
не всі
аплікації і розказати як змінюється
взагалі ситуація
національній системі кваліфікації чи в
районі є чи мені розбудовуємо чи ми все
ж таки говоримо в такому звиклим вам
поняттям ринок праці є рівні
ще раз усім Доброго дня я перед тим як
почати свій виступ я просив би щоб
увімкнули ролик який показував
ватись понад 30 кваліфікаційних центрів
можна підтвердити понад 150 професійних
кваліфікацій визнається професійних
кваліфікація здобути за кордоном якщо в
тебе немає кваліфікації закладу освіти
проте ти маєш професійні навички у
результаті самоосвіти чи трудової
діяльності підтвердити свій професійний
рівень можна в одному з кваліфікаційних
центрів що в переліку на сайті
національного агентства кваліфікації
вимоги до професії можна дізнатися у
кваліфікаційному центрі чи на сайті НАК
у розділі реєстр кваліфікацій що
підтвердити професійну кваліфікацію туди
необхідно подати заяву до
кваліфікаційного центру пройти
співбесіду та отримати інформацію щодо
процедури оцінювання успішно виконати
теоретичне та практичне завдання
Якщо хочеш жити в успішній європейській
країні приходь кваліфікаційний центр
підтверджує свою професійну кваліфікацію
офіційно працевлаштовується Та отримуй
гідну заробітну плату
дякую
всі прочитали
Насправді я згадав виступ Олени
колесникової Коли я навчався на
радіотехніці у Львівській політехніці і
було 8 березня
не багато потрібно було збирати грошей
для наших дівчат тому що їх було всього
Двоє в трьох групах Тому це насправді
виклик але виклик який можна долати
я сподіваюся з моєї презентацією буде
по-іншому ніж було з відео Там і клікер
а клікер є взагалі
А теж треба чекати так
про що про що варто говорити варто
говорити про ось той плакат який там на
стіні розміщений це знання нової доби
повсюди у книгах у смартфонах в
інтернеті і тому сьогодні не складає
особливої складності здобути нову якусь
кваліфікацію будучи навіть у себе вдома
або Працюючи на якісь роботі здобуваючи
працюючи по одній кваліфікації але
здобути її паралельно іншу тому виклик у
цьому всьому це визнання неформальної
інформації освіти ця вся річ вона є
частиною Я б сказав освіти для тих хто
вже має освіту це частина того що
сьогодні вимагає економіка і
традиційна освіта не може цього
забезпечити тому з'являється такі
інструменти і актуальність цих
інструментів вона є очевидно через те що
ось є кількість кваліфікаційних центрів
36 це вже неправда тому що сьогодні
зранку ми акредитували ще два У нас є
кількість експертів 248 це правда і
унікальних професійних кваліфікацій 149
це про що що це за цифра 149 це цифра
про те на що є попит чому це цифра на що
є попит через те що
держава не фінансує створення
кваліфікаційних центрів вони само
створюються вони створюються на базі
закладів професійної освіти на базі
закладів іншої освіти на базі
підприємств об'єднань роботодавців і
вони створюються самі собою їх не
потрібно штовхати вони самі стоять в
черзі і в нас таких справ зараз на
розгляді боюся помилитися десь приблизно
10 що це дає це дає насправді класний
інструмент і реальний інструмент
організації людського капіталу в Україні
як такого десь приблизно місяць тому я
був в одній області в якій трохи шиють
трохи продають так вони створили
кваліфікаційний центр акредитувалися в
нас пройшли процедуру все
сертифікували людей присвоїли їм
професійні кваліфікації Тепер ти
працівники
приносять їм більше грошей тому
підприємству через що через те що вони
насправді виконували свою роботу якісно
але так вони її виконували якісно чи не
так не було зрозуміло вони сертифікували
їх ті сертифіковані працівники виконали
роботу Ця продукція з підтвердженням
того що вона виконана сертифікованими
робітниками поїхала в Європу І знаєте що
змінилося кількість замовлення на ту
продукцію збільшилась і вартість цієї
продукції збільшилась це означає що ми
класно створили цей інструмент і цей
інструмент дії Він працює тепер що
стосується по кількості присвоєних
професійних кваліфікацій ось цифра 1504
Ну я думаю що вона вже вже є більшою а
от заяв на проведення процедуру
акредитації є 9 це напевно
відкоригувати бо ми її позавчора робили
цю інформацію а сьогодні я вже справи
нові розписував на початок процедури як
акредитації
хтось вважає що система кваліфікаційних
центрів це там є
конкуренція
професійно-технічної освіти Чи
професійній освіти Чи па- фахові
передвище це може казати тільки та
людина яка не розібралася ці всі теми
тому що це додатковий інструмент який
дозволяє Сьогодні в нашій країні зробити
те що не можна було зробити до появи 986
постанови яка
регламентує процедуру акредитації
кваліфікаційного центру це є відповідь
на те що потрібно тому що
вони створюються тільки за потреби ніхто
штучно це не створює ніхто не виділяє на
це там навіть 5 грн для того щоб цей
кваліфікаційний центр створився сам він
створить це основна ознака того що на це
є потреба тепер що стосується е-е самих
цих базових вимог до професій чи про те
які коледж має бути в майбутньому
назвемо це так ну по-перше
професії професії та самі вимоги до тих
професій які зараз є вони змінюються
змінюється тому що змінюється час коли я
був на першому курсі в мене був Pentium
2 тепер все це компенсується в два рази
або в 10 раз смартфоном звичайно і немає
і ми не можемо це зупинити Тому нам цей
процес варто очолювати і Міністерство
цифрової трансформації вони досить такі
динамічні й активні і вони зрозуміли
коли в порядку розроблення введення в
перегляду професійних стандартів вони
заклали обов'язково вимогу наявності
цифрової компоненти усіх професійних
стандартів це прекрасно це означає що
якщо завтра у нас розробляється
професійний стандарт немає значення на
кого чи це бухгалтер кранівник вони
здається навіть і є або заявки є То вони
будуть обов'язково вмістити цифрову
компонент Якщо завтра Міністерство
освіти переглядає професійний стандарт
вчителя то вони обов'язково мають
вмістити цю компоненти і вже цим
майбутнім вчителям які будуть вчитися
педагогічних вузах з врахуванням
професійного стандарту це обов'язкова
норма вони будуть мати цифрові навички
через те що це Must have
якщо
кар'єрного радника про якого ви говорите
цей кар'єрний радник вони одно
оновлювати будуть професійний стандарт
вони оновлюють його відповідно до нових
вимог тому професійний стандарт - це
основа з основ за які треба братися які
потрібно робити тому що це прекрасна
інвестиція в українську економіку тому
що ти в системі яка існує
створюєш і диктуєш правила для всієї
системи освіти тому що система освіти
обов'язково зобов'язана використати
професійний стандарт у своїй освітній
програмі якщо вона хоче присвоїти
професійну кваліфікацію а ринок праці не
цікавить Де ти вчився і Як ти вчився
його цікавить твоя кваліфікація що ти
конкретно вмієш тому що бізнес приватний
державний сектор економіки він
обов'язково там потрібно вирішувати
якусь проблему в приватному секторі
заробляти гроші в державному секторі
виконувати конкретні завдання якщо ти їх
не можеш виконувати ти не ну тебе будуть
змінювати
по кількості заявок на розроблення
професійних стандартів 221 і
заявки на внесення змін і ці кількість
кількість росте тому що коли Національне
агентство кваліфікації створилося то
таких професійних стандартів спочатку
було 9 тоді стало 12 і нічого тенденції
непогані Мені це все імпонує
клікер теж не працює так
мав би працювати там станція тому туди
якщо можна її туди
слайда була Може попередній
Так
це інформація про те де кваліфікаційні
центри створення Сьогодні ми ще
акредитували у Рівному і акредитували в
Кривому Розі
в Кривому Розі в Кривому Розі так і ось
тенденція про що це говорить якщо хтось
сьогодні
прифронтовій зоні Я говорю про Дніпро Я
говорю про Запоріжжя Я говорю про суми я
говорю про Миколаїв і говорю про Одесу
хтось створює там кваліфікаційні центри
значить на це є попит це відповідь на те
хто потрібен сьогодні там для того щоб
відбудовувати Бо насправді ці регіони
які Я назвав вони найбільше постраждали
і це і це правда тому Шановні колеги я
бачу коледжі майбутнього які будуть мати
формальну компоненту визнання ну
навчання і неформального компоненту
визнання професійних кваліфікацій Чому
Тому що це це більшість спектр це більша
можливість для закладу
Приймати участь в організації людського
капіталу крім того я
поцікавився скільки коштує присвоєння
професійних кваліфікацій різних очевидно
коли мене запитують А скільки коштує
присвоєння професійної кваліфікації це
немає однозначної відповіді бо це
нереально дати відповідь по присвоєння
професійної кваліфікації бухгалтера Це
одні видатки матеріально-технічні а
присвоєння професійної кваліфікації
кранівника це інші видатки тому тільки
все одно порядок цифр від до приблизно
ну і присвоєння професійної кваліфікації
практично психолога
приблизно в кваліфікаційному центрі всім
з половиною тисяч але є наприклад
підприємства або об'єднання підприємств
які створюють кваліфікаційний центр не з
ціллю організації бізнесу а з ціллю того
щоб організувати свій внутрішній
людський капітал тому що в них є тисячі
людей аби там сотні людей які вміють
Щорс робити і вони за рахунок
кваліфікаційного центру вирішують свої
внутрішні проблеми і це правильно і це
класно це зрозуміло це означає що в нас
по-перше будуть декінізація
ринку праці по-друге у нас буде реально
Об'єктивна інформація Хто в нас працює
Бо насправді
в класифікаторі професій були відсутні А
які професії а звітність подають
бухгалтери через ЄСВ через код
класифікатора Так я вам розповім що мій
одногрупник з яким я навчався на
радіотехніці він працював в одній
it-компанії а насправді був оформлений
для того щоб до них не було претензій
охоронцем то як ми можемо всі його
девелопера по зві- звітність подати по
ньому по охоронці
проблема є Юрію Я перепрошую ми маємо
певний ліміт по часу і думаю що ми
продовжимо вже потім Спілкування
за чашкою кави тут дійсно виникає дякую
вам дуже Юрію
тут дійсно виникає питання підтвердження
кваліфікації відмінності професій від
кваліфікації це ми окремо конференцію
проводить Національне агентство
кваліфікації про людський капітал і ми з
задоволенням теж беремо участь А зараз я
хочу попросити пані Марію все ж таки
розказати про те дослідження про яке я
не знаю насправді Бо я думала що я знаю
все виявляється не все і Давайте
подумаємо А як себе в майбутньому в яких
професіях бачу себе молодь діти і
можливо якими би Вони хотіли бачити свій
заклад освіти якщо вони відповідно Про
це говорять Дякую та супер Всім доброго
дня я так розумію що у нас таймінг
досить
маленькі тому я швидко
найголовніше Мене звати Марічка я
засновниця керівниці благодійного фонду
клуб добродій який створений з метою
допомоги дітям і підліткам напевно нам
вже варто зробити футболку Але в
тінейджест тому сьогодні я буду голосом
молодих людей підлітків з якими ми
працюємо безпосередньо в наших
неформальних програмах а також в лютому
цього року ми провели велике дослідження
підлітки їх життя під час війни для того
щоб правильно дізнатися А яке їх життя
Що змінилося яким чином нам потрібно
трансформувати наше дослідження наші
програми і це дослідження мала великий
резонанс багато вчителів
представників освітня державних
громадського сектору брали його
цитувати що найголовнішого по-перше якщо
б зараз ми закінчився мій виступ теза
яка прозвучала від підлітків на
дискусійні панелі це нічого про
підлітків без підлітків вони готові і
хочуть Приймати участь у відбудові вони
готові хочуть бачити себе в тому числі в
формувальних програм і насправді вони
дуже багато речей можуть порадити
дорослим нам з вами як зробити ще краще
для них тому найголовніший інсайти і
найголовніші якісь
запити мають бути до цієї цільової
аудиторії з якою ми працюємо
безпосередньо з молодими людьми які
ключові показники цікаві в рамках даної
саме панелі нагадаю що дослідження
називається підлітки їх життя під час
війни Google багато є матеріалів А ви
обов'язково знайдете посилання були як і
фокус групи так і велике Всеукраїнське
дослідження тож там є і пряма мова і
цифри факти які вам знадобляться що
найважливіше 67% підлітків в Україні
знають знають ким хочуть стати в
майбутньому і це відсоток значно виріс
саме під час війни Війна як спонукала
визначитися і спонукала знайти таку
певну точку опори бачення того ким вони
як вони будуть реалізовуватися а майже
чверть визначилися саме під час війни
9%
6%. вирішила брати військову професію
для них це важливо вони хочуть бути
частиною відбудови і так само важливо
розуміти що використовувати дуже активно
будуть саме вони і тому в усіх зараз
дискусійних панелях різних розробках
планів ми дуже часто не враховуємо їх
голос Хоча і їх руками це буде і
робитися тому це важливо також також що
ще цікавого про те що саме реалізація це
для нас цікаве як для фонду тому що ми
працюємо над тим і хочемо давати
інструменти такою пошуку точку опору
всередині себе бути адаптивними гнучкими
до викликів сучасного світу і ми
запитали їх про те що таке
самореалізація і більшість відповіла про
те що самореалізація це займатися тією
справою і бути в цій професії яка
приносить тобі задоволення і Який у тебе
класно вдається насправді у них
внутрішні компаси досить активно
розвинені і вони дійсно шукають себе в
цьому світі і я хочу підтримати
просопські ли емоційний інтелект різні
підходи до цієї теми але насправді моя
особиста думка я би хотіла додати до
всього сказаного що Hard Skillet - це
класно Але якщо ми не будемо вивозити цю
реальність яка невідома яка буде завтра
хард скіли нам насильна допоможе тому на
рівні з Hardkiss нам потрібно розвивати
Soft скіли нам потрібно розвиватися
разом з підлітками і це також один із
таких леймотивів які був в нашому
дослідженні вони не хочуть чути прямих
відповідей вони хочуть Разом з дорослими
шукати ці відповіді і є шикарні практики
міжнародні коли там уроки з теорії або
будь-які іншої проводять через розвиток
креативності аналітику критичного
мислення і це те що потрібно у них
розвивати
речеєм доступ знань до Hardkiss
професійних скелів які мають бути для
реалізації в ті часів іншій професії Я
якраз представниця хочу вже насильно
молодь але представниця що
вступаючим університет Я нікому не могла
подумати що місія мого життя буде на
комерційний сектор тому до цього Також
потрібно бути готовим вони також не
знають 25% зазначили що у них немає
розуміння які професії будуть в
майбутньому але це відсоток не про те що
все пропало О Боже скажіть ким ми маємо
стати а відсоток про те що світ дуже
швидкозмінний світ дає нам дуже
Випробування складні і насправді ніхто
не може з вангувати які професії
потрібні буде через 5-10-15 років
можливо щось ми не можемо побачити
усвідомити і найголовніше це бути
відкритими до нового бути однією
командою разом з молодими людьми і
розвивати скіли не менше ніж хартскіли
тому що саме софскіли допоможуть дітям
дуже швидко і гнучко і без болісно для
самих себе за потреби змінити професію
знайти перезібрати себе наново Дякую
Марічко аплодисменти колеги в нас за 10
хвилин почнеться наступна панель але я
обіцяла вам сесію питань відповідей від
себе я вже питань більше задавати не
буду чи є у когось зараз нагальне
питання до наших спікерів до когось із
наших спікерів
Чи все було Зрозуміло Ну Наразі я не
бачу піднятих рук а це означає що в
принципі дуже все чітко було окреслено
нашими спікерами ще раз дуже дякую всім
хто сьогодні долучився до нашої панелі
нагадую
нагадую за 10 хвилин починається
наступний етап де ми будемо говорити
власне взагалі про те які мають бути
коледжі майбутнього будемо фантазувати
коротенька перерва Дякую шалено і до
нових зустрічей
Боже як добре що у нас на панелі 5
спікерів а не шість вони відміни від
пані Ірини зможе сидіти Це дуже зручно
і так друзі у нас починається наступна
частина нашої панельної дискусії яка
присвячена коледжем майбутнього власне
пані Ірина нам минулій панелі
проанансували Що ми сьогодні будемо
говорити про Поточний стан справ і
мріяти
але на попередній панелі вдалось
поговорити про Поточний стан справ А
тепер ми будемо мріяти значить оскільки
Ну ми всі розуміємо що під час війни
виникає дуже великий спектр викликів
питання які необхідно вирішувати в тому
числі ці питання стоять в системі освіти
а для нас очевидно що
відбудовувати старе з усіма його
недоліками
буде не зовсім розумно і ми спробуємо
сьогодні подумати про те А як
відбудовуючи країну відбудовуючи систему
освіти відбудовуючи систему про
техосвіти А ми можемо вкласти в неї нові
сенси нові візі нові ідеї і власне У нас
сьогодні чудовий склад спікерів я хочу
представити пана Петра коржевського
директора Департаменту освіти і науки
Рівненської обласної
військово-адміністрації
а пані Ярославу жирун
директорку північного центру професійної
освіти Одеської області А пане Дмитра
Завгороднього заступника міністра освіти
і науки України з питання профтехосвіти
і цифровізації я це вимовив
Влада мінчева креативного копірайтора
рекламної агенції bikerstar що створює
дуже круту рекламну комунікацію
і Вікторія Тітова сіо bigcity Lab - це
урбаністична організація яка займається
відбудовою ревіталізацією і створенням
нових сенсів в Старих просторах
і напевно що з простріл Ми сьогодні і
спробуємо почати
а Вікторія
ми знаємо
спробуємо включити
а він ввімкнений все добре Так ми знаємо
що сьогодні існує величезна кількість
закладів профтехосвіти коледжів
що працюють в Старих будівлях переважно
будівлях не модернізованих частинах
будівель є пошкодженими через війну або
недофінансованими і ми маємо шукати
шляхи як зробити так щоб простір в якому
навчаються підлітки діти і дорослі був
привабливим щоб він був не мінусом а
плюсом щоб він заохочував людей вступати
в систему простих освіти в сучасній
професійні коледжі поділись будь ласка
своїм поглядом своїм досвідом які ми
мають бути ці простери які залучатимуть
до себе дітей дякую
Доброго дня всім
ми тільки починаємо насправді працювати
з протехами тому багато чого Я ще
сьогодні буду говорити це швидше роздуму
ніж якби Догма чи Панацея але про що ми
думаємо Коли ми у навіть клікер дають на
цій панелі
про що ми думаємо коли ми говоримо про
техосвіту це про те що вона має
відповідати саме архітектура про те хоч
і коледжу має закривати три базові речі
перше Вона має показувати відмінність
від старшої школи тому що насправді Це ж
такі самі діти такі самі підлітки
16-17-18 19 років які навчаються і в
старшій школі але при цьому Ну вони вже
отримують професію вони вже вступають в
доросле життя вони вже живуть окремо
вони набагато швидше дорослішають і
відповідно оця відмінність в тому числі
в архітектурі і в дизайні Вона має бути
присутня друге - це
архітектура створює привабливість того
чи іншого навчального закладу
той чи інший майстерні навіть якщо сам
заклад може бути старенький і і
подряпаний але якщо конкретно ваша
майстерня ваша кафедра знаходиться в
супер крутому місці Це вже дуже великий
плюс для навіть самооцінки тієї людини
яка отримує цю професію яка в
майбутньому її виконувати і нести її в
світ і Третє - це архітектура як
будь-яка форма вона має слідувати за
суттю тобто спочатку ми говоримо про те
які програми в наших профтехах які
потреби освітян про втехах як
викладається той чи інший предмет як
типу які потреби в тій чи іншій
майстерні і вже Після цього ми маємо
формувати простір тобто спочатку задача
а потім за нею слідкує простір так
куди направляти Підкажіть ага є і
Якщо говорити про те як ми можемо
трансформувати це простір отакий раз Ось
ця тема в якій нам не треба нічого
вигадувати тут Ну насправді немає нічого
креативного тут не повинно бути ноу-хау
Як таких звичайними ми маємо вносити це
все свій характер і своє бачення але
загалом те як працювати з коледжами чи
професійно-технічними школами дуже
багато країн вже навчилися як це робити
ми подивилися на досвід
Швейцарії Німеччини і Австрії які дуже
круто працюють з цим напрямком і
намагалися розібратися як вони до цього
підходять і що тут важливо що при
відбудові навряд чи нас вийде зробити
так щоб ми беремо кожен профтех і
реконструємо від А до Я швидше за все це
будуть якісь точки в ремонти Тут і там і
ось це лоскутність І відсутність
цілісного проекту вона і створює
неохайність певну Вона створює
вона знижує якість архітектури загальної
але при цьому якщо ми Який в нас підхід
якщо ми беремо якусь будівлю яка має
певний функціонал неважливо якою ця
будівля форми не важливо Ну типу де вона
знаходиться і так далі в неї перше за
все має йти функція і кожна і кожна
функціональна зона має відповідати цій
функції відповідно для того щоб
розібратися що робити з профтехами ми
можемо
Я особисто ми можемо всі разом
запит на кожну з цих функцій і далі
архітекторі описують Наприклад якщо ми
говоримо про хорошу вхідну групу от
заходить викладач студент просто в
будівлю про втеху чи батьки чи гості Яка
функція вхідної групи це ж не просто
зайти і пройти далі це отримати певну
інформацію це зустрітися поглядами це
мати можливість відійти в сторонку з
кимось поговорити це залишити одяг чи
можливо не залишати одяг це сісти
відпочити і так далі І так у кожної
функції яка є у вас в будівлі є свої
задачі у функціональної зони і розуміючи
задачі функціональної зони ми можемо
описати до кожної з них кедлайни і тоді
я зараз показую якісь дуже такі модні
гарні приклади про втехів закордонних
але насправді облаштувати
простір який в якому буде комфортно
можна в будь-якій зоні це те що ми зараз
робимо зі школами Я розказувала на
попередній панелі про відбудову школа ми
трошки простіше тому що там є типові
будівлі радянських шкіл мабуть всі
бачили школа літерою н літерою п літерою
т і так далі І там можна розробити саме
проект такої трансформації тут буде
складніше тут потрібно буде йти
лоскутним таке таким все-таки лоскутним
методом Але тим не менш опрацьовують
просто навіть для себе да тут Мабуть що
всі люди хто тут сидять в залі Зараз це
люди які займаються коледжами і
професійно-технічною освітою просто
подумайте що таке ідеальна бібліотека
саме в контексті профтеху що таке
ідеальна їдальня в контексті профтеху
чим вона може відрізнятися від їдальні в
старшій школі аби в дитсадочку ну тобто
є ж різниця правда і задаючи собі ці
питання ми можемо Таким чином пройтись
по всіх загальних зонах але профтех це ж
не про загальні зони це не лише
гуртожиток і кафетерій е це в першу
чергу різні
імітації робочих місць і майстерні
відповідно для того щоб працювати з цим
можна робити такі самі підхід в кожного
профтеху Я так розумію своя
спеціалізація які професії в нього
входять і визначають що ось цей перелік
спеціалізації ми розуміємо що є
наприклад
мистецькі майстерні є наприклад
комп'ютерні лабораторії і в кожного в
кожного з цих зон знову ж таки є вимоги
що такий ідеальна дизайн художньої
студії як вона має виглядати що в ній
був простір для думки тобто швидше за
все вона не має бути сама розмальована
бо інакше там ну вона якби створює вже
певний простір вона фреймуть мозок вони
швидше за все вона має бути максимально
там світла повітряна без зайвих
елементів але при цьому з дошками для
роботи щоб свою ідею можна було
розкласти на стіні те саме там для
музики те саме вимоги для комп'ютерних
лабораторій якщо ми говоримо про
інженерії або кулінарію тут уже йде в
першу чергу технологія тобто яким чином
ми працюємо з технологією кухні як ми
показуємо що таке планування хорошої
професійної кухні Щоб
студенти звикали працювати в
професійному досвіді тому що готувати
можна і вдома і на кухні в гуртожитку
але це відрізняється від роботи в
ресторані потрібно розуміти якби яким
чином себе поводити в професійному
середовищі
абсолютно І далі так само рухаємось до
імітаційних кімнат
ми коли так робите Я бачу лише своє
обличчя і не бачу що написано
так
кімната симуляції центр Ага так
відповідно якщо ми говоримо особливо про
медичні коледжі це окрема історія якщо
ми говоримо про спеціальність по типу
сантехнічні інженерні столярні і так
далі Кожен з них має мати певне
відображення тієї професії в яку діти
будуть рухатися тобто дизайн медичних
медичних коледжів має повторювати дизайн
лікарень які вони потім підуть працювати
якщо ми говоримо про не знаю там
механіків то вони мають працювати в
просторі який відповідає
автомайстерні або
мати можливість працювати столярним
станком але які стіни їх оточують які
меблі їх оточують який характер у цих
меблів він в кожного разу має бути
різним залежно від тієї професії це
більш мистецька
[музика]
Чи це більш індустріальна естетика чи це
навпаки супер чиста клінічна стерильна
медична естетика і так далі і відповідно
наш підхід який пропрацьовуючи кожну з
таких зон окремо
як ми зазвичай працюємо ми беремо
будь-який заклад з будь-яким
функціоналом виписуємо всі сезони
вивчаємо міжнародний досвід як
міжнародними досвід і працюють з кожною
з таких зон буквально пропаруємо
закордонний профтех і далі ключова
історія це долучити людей які з цими про
втехими працюють хто ними керує хто в
них викладає хто для них пише програми і
таким чином ми з вас як з кінцевого
користувача як з клієнта знімаємо ось цю
задачу
проганяємо її через фільтри міжнародного
досвіду
і формулюємо технічне завдання по
ідеальному
профтехучилищі і ці гайдлайни вони далі
можуть використовуватись будь-яким
закладом і незалежно від того хто в
нього донор хто замовник це місцева
Влада чи це велика національна програма
відбудови це якби може бути такий спосіб
роботи з архітектурою але що тут ще
важливо про що дуже рідко згадують це
про технологічну частину архітектури
Наприклад тут сьогодні дуже гарно але
дуже мало повітря жахливо будуть голова
те саме історія з навчальними просторами
де фізіологічний стан людини напряму
впливає на її результати Ми
пропрацьовували різні там системи
вентиляції освітлення і так далі І
наприклад те От мені зараз теж світить
прожектор Ну я потерплю але мені не
писати зараз екзамени розумієте і
Відповідно ми пропрацьовували яка
теплота світла має бути в кімнаті для
того щоб це не тиснуло дітей а
створювало знову допомагала їм
вирішувати свої задачі а не заважало аби
наприклад є Дослідження які говорять про
те що
є нормальна температура в кімнаті там
від 21 до 24,5 градусів все що на 1
градус вище або нижче створює настільки
великий дискомфорт що діти які в цей час
приходять екзамен втрачають по декілька
пунктів от просто в середньому схожі
скошується відповідно коли ми говоримо
про
відбудову нам в першу чергу потрібно
розуміти як ми можемо створити простір
який допомагає вчитися а не заважає тому
що я наприклад вчилася в КПІ і в нас
було ці величезні лекторії
в радянських корпусах які дуже гарні
модерністська архітектура і так далі але
в них просто було ну неможливо холодно
взимку і мені цікаво скільки скільки
не дотримали з одногрупниками через те
що ми просто тупо мерзли тому Ось так от
е-е вентиляція освітлення електрика
опалення кількість природного освітлення
в залі вона частково регулюється дбнами
Але знову ж таки ДБН ну державне
будівельна норма не змінювалася по
освіті досить-таки давно А якщо
змінювалась то так незначно і відповідно
Це просто знову ж таки для вас Якщо ви
будете починати якісь зміни в
архітектурному просторі теж тримайте це
до уваги що ось ці речі які ну нібито
архітектори мають самі розібратися як з
цим працювати Вони теж мають бути
технічним завданням для них з вашого
боку тому що це напряму буде впливати на
ті результати дітей яких ви навчаєте
яка а дуже практичне питання чи існують
сьогодні якісь посібники які менеджер
заклади може подивитись
сьогодні такого посібника немає але є
посібники наприклад по різних напрямках
Дмитро каже Ми зробимо добре
Ми зробимо
Ми зробимо Якщо коротко якщо потрібно
вже що зараз
дивіться наразі загального немає але є
певні напрацювання по різних напрямках
Наприклад якщо ми говоримо про
інклюзивну освіту то знову ж таки Наша
команда розробляла альбом безболірних
рішень в рамках ініціативи першої леді
який абсолютно так само пропарує весь
простір і показує яким чином можна його
адаптувати так щоб люди з інвалідністю
або маломобільні групи могли ним
користуватися і відповідно з цим
напрямком точно можна працювати
як мінімум у вас має бути доступний вхід
доступне вбиральня і доступні маршрути
безбар'єрні пересування по по території
і по будівлі це якби базовий мінімум а
далі там мільйон деталей отака товста
книжка рекомендую почитати супер Дуже
дякую
прошу
чекайте
Я директор професійного ліцею звати Мене
Сергій я хотів би от ви говорите про те
що можна написати книгу написати
посібник створення будь-якого середовища
в ліцеї воно перше Ну
професійно-технічному навчальному
закладі воно вперше вимагає від нас той
хто буде менеджер Який його буде
створювати це тісна співпраця із дитячим
колективом з колективом тих учнів і учні
не бажають наприклад
бути там де їм нав'язали і коли ми От
наприклад створювали ми були в
експерименті створення
освітньо-розвивального середовища і
освітнього виробничого середовища і де
ми з учнівським колективом обговорювали
про те щоб ви хотіли які б ви зміни
хотіли привезти то ми в першу чергу
звертали на Що на гроші і я б хотів
задати питання хто буде з'ясувати ці
зміни
тому що це дуже великі і ще хочу вам
сказати таке питання що
от будь-яке середовище будь-яке
середовище воно не може бути постійним
Воно повинно змінюватися Ну
дуже-дуже-дуже час то і я на прикладі
свого навчального закладу хочу сказати
що це все пов'язано із навчанням от
дуальна форма здобуття освіти Ми
наприклад в рік заробляли по 3 млн грн і
тоді ми створювали Отакі локації як і
про які ви говорите ми їх створювали у
нас актова зала шикарна все зроблено на
превеликий жаль зараз в окупації то ми
не знаємо що там залишиться але без
учнів без учнівського самоврядування без
тісної співпраці із тими людьми які там
працюють ніяка книжка не замінить І саме
головне фінансування саме головне
фінансування по першій частині потім
питання фінансування перед мікрофон пана
дмитру Дивіться по-перше ви дуже круті
що ви це робите і ну типу ви проводите
ці консультаційні сесії з учнями сто
відсотків так і потрібно робити це те що
я почала що ми типу є дві речі які
потрібно вивчати міжнародний досвід і
досвід конкретний локальний що яка
конкретна потреба І цей досвід і
вчительський і досвід учнівський І
наприклад там по школах де ми зараз
рухаємося трохи швидше ми вже провели
такі
фасилітації фокус-групи з
старшокласниками І це дає дуже круті
результати А ще крутіше - це те що вони
на цих це були представники учнівського
самоврядування і вони в результаті цих
фасолідацій не тільки що нам
порекомендували що робити але ще й самі
зрозуміли що дуже багато речей в
принципі не ну типу якихось маленьких не
вимагають ви мабуть нічого не чуєте з
того що я вам зараз розказую
Вікторія дякую Я думаю що у нас дуже
багато питань будуть переходити формат
де взяти гроші і побачили цей хотів
сказати що це буде останнє питання це
буде останнє питання тому що банк Дмитро
для цього тут і присутні для того щоб
відбуватись на питання яке всім болить у
всіх цікавить але я би хотів зараз
передати слово пану Петру і поцікавитись
його досвідом впровадження
прогресивних підходів до закладів
профтехосвіти в Рівненській області тому
що у вас справді дуже цікавий і крутий
досвід і це якраз досвід дуже практичний
і мені здається що в даному випадку
цікаво поговорити не тільки про
приміщення Хоча це дуже важливо а й про
цінності і принципи які ви вкладаєте в
розвиток закладів пан Петро Порошенко
Дякую насправді
насправді дуже би хотілося говорити про
ідею створення
професійної освіти нового покоління для
нового покоління Оскільки сьогодні такої
наскрізної ниткою упродовж всіх
панельних дискусій ми говоримо про те що
не варто відновлювати
пострадянський простор варто будувати
нові не знаю чи в системі професійної
освіти так можна
фундаментально все змінити але іти
шляхом створення навчально-практичних
центрів можна цим самим формувати такі
заклади професійної освіти які були би
інвестиційно привабливими що важливо
важливо аби заклад був інвестиційно
привабливим Ми формуємо трудовий
потенціал для регіону який ми хочемо щоб
був інвестиційно привабливий так от щоб
він був інвестиційно привабливим
необхідно щоб все починаючи від учня
який обирає той чи інший заклад І той
простір в якої який він обирає в цьому
навчальному закладі
робив його успішним і він справді міг би
зреалізувати свою мрію отримати найкращу
роботу у на найкращому підприємстві з
найкращою оплатою праці в майбутньому
створити власний бізнес який би створив
нові робочі місця який би дав можливість
таким як він в майбутньому молодим людям
обрати Саме цей навчальний заклад і
здобувати освіту але уявіть собі уявіть
собі скільки чинників
скільки чинників оцієї крутої так званої
системи створення професійної освіти
нового покоління для нового покоління ми
маємо розуміти що з такою мережею яка є
жоден регіон не справиться бо вона
неефективна І ми до цього йшли 17 років
якщо ви думаєте що ці круті кейси про
які Ми розказуємо то це все безболісно
ні Якщо ви думаєте що було без втрат ні
Якщо ви думаєте що не прийшлося говорити
про м'які навички про які ніхто не хоче
говорити директор хоче чути дайте гроші
я все зроблю а я хочу давати гроші тому
освітньому менеджеру у якому Я впевнений
що він ці кошти використає ефективно що
після того коли Він отримує ці кошти
збільшиться кількість здобувачів освіти
що збільшиться кількість тих дітей які
оберуть роботу або створить робочі місця
Я хочу розуміти яку ж додану вартість
від того чи іншого випускниками
отримуємо в майбутньому ми розуміємо що
якісний на якісний освітній простір
можливо і прийдуть А як виміряти який
освітній простір якісний А це уже е-е
один із чинників - Це так зване це
сарафанне радіо бо всі знають що
вступивши у Цей заклад ти точно отримуєш
роботу або навчають тебе створити власну
справу маємо розуміти що ключовим в
освітньому середовищі є педагог і цей
педагог має розуміти що навчання
упродовж життя - це неминуча норма
сучасного сучасного педагога ми маємо
розуміти що керівник закладу це не
просто директор це освітній менеджер
який вміє робити бюджетний запит
формувати його робити зміни які вміє
відкрити всі коди видатки економічної
діяльності які знає що на що йде що його
не можуть
притягнути до відповідальності за
нецільове використання коштів ви думаєте
таких освітніх менеджерів багато я Собі
уявляю скільки проектів Ми з реалізували
щоб навчити керівників писати
бізнес-плани щоб вони розуміли в який
спосіб можна діяти в тій чи іншій
ситуації в яких які громадські
організації можна залучити ну власне Не
все так не все так як вам здається що
дати грошей і зразу все стає так як би
хотілося
але ключове
студент чи учень як на це в майбутньому
визначеному мені дуже пасує оця назва
коледжі майбутнього от мені би дуже
хотілося щоб у коледжах майбутнього було
ті молоді люди які будуть формувати
майбутнє краю в якому вони навчаються і
України в цілому і дуже би хотілося щоб
не всі чекали коли раптом звідкись
звалиться величезний чемодан як правило
без ручки з величезною кількістю грошей
так не буває кожен із нас це людський
капітал ми маємо формувати людський
капітал ми маємо формувати такі цінності
аби молоді люди обирали заклади
професійної освіти в тому регіоні де
вони навчаються або подай в Україні
сьогодні міністр виголосив що людина має
мати право навчатися там де вона хоче і
стати тим ким вона хоче власне це наша
ключова задача яку ми маємо в них
сформувати але ці цінності не стаються
після дев'ятого чи 11 класу ці цінності
формуються в родині ці цінності
формується в дошкіллі ці цінності
формуються загальній середній освіті
цінності формуються там де вчитель каже
Не іди зі школи після дев'ятого класу бо
в мене в 10-му класі не буде учнів не
буде класу не буде годин ми маємо бути
взаємовідповідальні за усе що діється у
цілісній освітній сфері і це теж та
відповідальність на яку ну Напевно
покликані кожен із нас на своєму на
своєму місці де ми робимо Я впевнений що
нам вистачить мудрості сформувати саме
таку професійну освіту
чи для цього треба дуже багато грошей я
думаю що для цього треба дуже багато
часу аби самим себе переконати в це
повірити вчитися упродовж усього життя І
передавати свої знання в майбутньому
поколінням
[оплески]
пане Петро Дуже дякую Дуже надихаючи
думки І хотілося б перейти до вашого
досвіду п Ярослава власне ви створили в
Одеській області 11 закладів які всюди
наводять приклад і його я всюди чую про
те що ви зробили щось таке неможливе і
надзвичайне і це якраз чудовий приклад
того що зміни про які ми зараз говоримо
вони можливі їх можна втілювати дуже
цікаво як ви це робите І які принципи
вкладаєте
Дякую
Вітаю Тетяни дуже приємно і надзвичайно
зворушено що
запрошена на таке поважне зібрання і маю
честь сьогодні бути спікером на
панельній дискусії як зробити заклади
привабливими оскільки очолюваний мною
заклад знаходиться у сільській
місцевості то я хочу сказати що це не
просто
змагатися із
навчальними закладами міста у
привабливості у можливостях у
потужностях але все-таки це можливо і я
постараюся дуже коротесенько розповісти
на прикладі північного центру
професійної освіти який був створений у
2018 році шляхом об'єднання трьох
аграрних абсолютно однакових училищ один
багатопрофільний центр
Але до цього до 18-го року була трохи
сумна історія я би сказала навіть мега
сумна тому що все було дуже так просто
стандартно
нецікаво і тоді
Ми вирішили поставити за мету змінити
захотілося змін захотілось щоб заклад
жив щоб дітям було в ньому комфортно щоб
вони захотіли прийти на навчання А ми в
свою чергу мали роботу у сільській
місцевості тому що знайти її там дуже
важко зібралися однодумці Я вважаю що
той хто прийшов працювати у профтех він
залюблений у цю професію сам профтех на
все життя І от були поставлені такі цілі
це зламати стереотип ПТУ підняти
престижність робітничої
робітничих професій
здивувати і переконати і
почали працювати
на
престижність на рекламу шляхом
презентації через професію і креативити
в рамках цих професій і поза ними І
знаєте от як у тій українській приказки
пішла
голитьба на вигадки і почали вигадувати
креативи тим
прибрали із їдальні чому з їдальні тому
що дивилася на своїх сирі та їх було
понадстою вони кричали що ніби їжа
смачна була Ніби все нормально але не
задоволені вони і я довго думала Ну що ж
таке Чому вони швиряють їжею я зрозуміла
вони не можуть в нас смачна але їм не
смачно тому що сприймають вони її
вживають її у некомфортному середовищі І
от ми почали з їдальні почали виготовили
меблі з якісної деревини а з відходів
робили декор створили
столи і стільчики
із старих списаних книжок і старих
тракторних дисків
але
вроді креативимо а дуже повільно йде Ця
історія і не можемо зрушити з місця і
така бентега взяла і я вирішила що Треба
напевно його якось матеріалізувати
трошки взяли оті відходи із тих дощок і
почали малювати картини саме тоді був
2016 рік у нас така команда цікава
зайшла
на одещину почали такі реформи проводити
потрібно було виживати
І от ми вирішили нас навіть хотіли
закрити вирішили
матеріалізувати оцю таку мрію нашого
навчального закладу був рік 2016 рік ми
англійською мовою так щоб для себе
тільки і для того хто розуміє написали
цілу філософію в тих картинах які ми
оздобили їдальню
відцвівші кульбаби які летять і
що якщо всі твої мрії збудуться
хтось бачить бур’яни А я бачу мрії
здійснення бажань у цих бур'янах і отак
ціла філософія і
почали дивувати почали креативити і
спрацювало наступним кроком
нашим попри креатив було переконати
місцеву владу що
ми потрібні громаді що вона не зможе без
нас існувати тому що професійна освіта
забезпечує якість життя
створили
гарний конференц-зал от Як говорив пан
Сергій І хочу сказати що дуже доречно що
тільки з дітьми можна створювати
середовище яке вони берегтимуть і в
якому вони захочуть навчатися і прийдуть
на навчання якому вони захочуть
перебувати виховуватимуться
створили
конференц-зал забезпечили гарний смачну
їжу і сервіс належний кейтерінг і до нас
почали звертатися і першим таким
проектом спільним із громадою Ми сіли
Прописали такий проект туристичний
проект чотири сезони коли у кожну пору
року
відбувається якийсь етнофестиваль восени
весняні гаївки влітку квітка папороті
який тривав п'ять діб і збирав Ну як для
сільської місцевості понад 10 тисяч
гостей і саме всі локації
будували учні
нашого закладу це і дерев'яні будинки
для
продажі сувенір сувенірної продукції це
і локації і для приготування споживання
їжі це в дерев'яний посуд такий
креативний в якому подавали
також була
[музика]
фестиваль Покрова героїв і на базі
нашого навчального закладу уже З оцим
таким креативним підходом була все був
проводив всеукраїнський семінар
патріотичного виховання
а також працює щороку У рамках цього
проекту Одеська резиденція Святого
Миколая яка розпочинається 19 грудня на
свято Святого Миколая закінчується на
Водохреща 19 січня І от У цей час наше
кафе їдальня перетворюється в кафе у
канцелярію Святого Миколая А
їдальня утрапи з нас Святого Миколая і
Щороку ми приймаємо до 5 тисяч гостей
які пишуть Там листи ну це це потужна
навчальна виробнича практика для усіх
студентів тому що потрібно зробити декор
відповідний потрібно нагодувати потрібно
прибрати і Ну не буду розповідати
ну це звичайно така профорієнтація
приїхали Діти в 5 класі через 3 роки
вони через чотири вони прийдуть там до
нас навчатися Тому що їм сподобається
наступним проектом було коли місцева
Влада зібрала бізнес і Бізнес зібрав
кошти а Влада виділила
ну депутатський корпус виділив і
придбали матеріали і обладнання А ми
учні разом із педагогами побудували
спортивний майданчик наступним проектом
було виділення коштів на придбання
плитки і учні за професією плиточник
вистелили цю плитку і знову креатив
плитки замало а тут і пожежники прийшли
пожежна водойма їм потрібно От ми і
вирішили зробити пожежну водойму потім
там поселилися
рибки як декор встановили фонтан із
труби зі старого духового оркестра яку
який неможливо було ніяк списати
сьогодні туди прилітають птахи п'ють
воду а потім коли почалась війна столяри
збудували міст А коло нього
десталізоване колесо яке вода падає а
воно крутиться а потім встановили високі
годівниці для голубів які прилетять
житимуть і принесуть нам звістку про
перемогу прилетіли живуть чекаємо на
звістку про перемогу Ну ось так живемо і
працюємо наразі ми працюємо над
створенням кулінарного хабу і
проводимо перемовини ну діалог із
місцевою владою для того щоб
в рамках шкільної реформи
заністиви перший лад Олени зеленської
годувати школярів громади і це не межа
Мені здається що потрібно три Віки щоб
ми реалізували усі ті проекти які у нас
у голові і підсумовуючи хочу сказати що
середовище має значення середовища
виховує навчає воно має бути комфортним
для учнів цілодобово тому що саме через
середовище вони сприймають світ вони
вчаться самоповаги і поваги до тих кому
в майбутньому вони забезпечуватимуть
якість життя Ну звичайно розказати все
про свій навчальний за я переконана що у
кожного із вас є свій рецепт успішності
привабливості неможливо вкластися в 5
хвилин а якщо бути конкретнішим То я
хочу сказати що якщо рухатися зі сторони
Києва то Одеська область починається
саме з Саврані а Одещина звісно гостинна
гостинний регіон Я запрошую до нас у
навчальний заклад усіх хто побажає і ми
разом будемо шукати шляхи для
подальшої привабливості навчальних
закладів професійних Дякую пане Ярослава
Дякую а Почекайте мене до вас ще одне
питання поки слухав хотілось спитати як
вам це вдається але ви вже пояснили
хотілося б спитати А чому ви би ще
хотіли навчитись для того щоб робити
свій заклад ще краще
потрібно підтримка Ну не сказала ще що
Знаєте коли ми зрушили і почали
креативити пішли інвестиції і Влада
долучилася і область долучилася за
сприяння Департаменту освіти у нас
створено чотири
навчально-практичних центрів це дуже
здорово що ці навчально-практичні центри
є
туристичного спрямування громадського
харчування деревообробних технологій
швейного виробництва це такий простір
для
діяльності для покращення і
привабливості навчального закладу ну
потрібно тільки допомога от не може
існувати сам чому хотіли
доволі предоксально я спробую підхопити
що можна очікувати коли фінанси прийдуть
А можна навчитись досвіду фандрейзингу
залучення коштів і отримати ці
результати тобто
не хотіла би навчитися писати там проект
і вигравати гранти На жаль дійсно
тут дуже вам дякую
[оплески]
Владислав тепер питання до тебе власне я
так коротко зараз представлю нашого
спікера Владислав є креативним
копірайтером рекламні агенції bitter
stuf це агенція яка робить прекрасні
рекламні компанії і може виникнути
питання
Чому Владислав сьогодні на цій панелі
про в тих освіти тому що про в тих
освіти ніби як заклади мало комунікують
але нам здалось що якраз саме цю
ситуацію і варто обговорити тому що для
того щоб залучати дітей для того щоб
залучати студентів до навчання заклади
мають мати не тільки гарні простори і не
тільки
цінності всередині світ має про це ще й
дізнатись і ми маємо подумати про те як
ми можемо комунікувати з зовнішнім
світом для того щоб він дізнавався що у
вас справді прекрасний заклад І тут
варто вчитись І як варто комунікувати
всередині для того щоб ваші учні
перетворювались в амбасадорів для того
щоб вони самі хотіли розповідати про
свій досвід навчання
прошу поділись будь ласка досвідом на
таких креативних комунікаційних підходів
е Всім привіт
мушу подякувати дуже пані ярославі тому
що вона вже частково дала відповідь на
ваше питання Я можливо дам трохи більше
теорії от я можливо не дам якихось
чітких рішень того як зараз зробити
коледж Але сподіваюсь трохи змінити ваше
ставлення до креативу і креативних
агенції і до того як вони можуть
взаємодіяти з клієнтами в тому числі з
коледжами і сподіваюсь це якраз в
майбутньому і допоможе нам зробити
коледжі привабливішими от а тому з моєї
точки зору і зважаючи на специфіку моєї
професії доцільно поговорити як зробити
коледжі привабливий що ми за допомогою
креативу а досі Чомусь у людей
люди плутають два Поняття творчість і
креатив І те і те по суті не обмежено
нічим крім вашої уяви Ну і можливо
інструмент інструментів доступних автору
але Будьмо відверто якщо інструментів у
вас лише телефон то ваші можливості по
суті майже безмежні
але творчість Вона має привілеї існувати
виключно заради творчості це
це артистичний вираження автора да Це
віддзеркалення його думок поглядів
креатив собі такого дозволити не може бо
креатив це по своїй суті творчість
автора Яка ще й вирішує певну проблему у
креативу завжди є обмежені рамки він
існує в чіткому контексті і завжди має
якусь певну мету
власне скіл вирішення проблем ми
відточуємо в креативних агенціях і вже в
процесі цього Ми створюємо рекламу
коли люди говорять про креатив в
контексті реклами Вони дуже часто чомусь
обмежують
потенційне прикладне використання цього
інструменту
Я говорю про те що люди сприймають
креатив Як тул для роботи з обгорткою а
не самою цукеркою і це створює таке
упередження що сам продукт не настільки
важливий як те як він поданий широкому
загалу і з'являється комунікації на
подобі кока-кольної да по суті що воно
продає вона продає повітря Ну типу це
сахарна вода от е-е але найдивніше не
дивніше в цьому це те що це працювало
але люди не тупі люди не стоять на місці
люди продовжують розвиватися рости
Вони стають більш
завбачливими більш вибагливими до
контенту який вони поглинають не
забуваємо що є рекламна сліпота і на неї
Ми продовжуємо встановлювати різні
оновлення і розширення з тим як який
короткий швидкий контент зараз
я в цьому питанні абсолютно не
безгрішний і будуть теж
короче створював креатив для товарів які
по суті не мали якихось відмінностей від
своїх конкурентів Та ну не мали чим
вирізнитись на ринку окрім власне якоїсь
унікальної стилістики їхньої комунікації
але
відчуття яке Ти отримуєш після таких
проектів воно відрізняється тому що якщо
вдалося донести людині якусь раціональну
перевагу то ти відчуваєш що ти зробив
щось корисне потенційно дав знання яке
якого в людини не було і яке зробить її
життя кращим чи хоча б легшим приємнішим
а от Коли все зводиться виключно до
продавання емоцій Ну в мене тіпа завжди
з'являється такий трохи неприємний
з'являвся Слава Богу
неприємний присмак після цього тому що
ти до кінця ніколи не знаєш чимало
людина реально Потребуєте її вирішив чи
ти придумав цю потре обов'язково додав
її до списку існуючих і вже вирішив ну
тіпа різниця насправді капітальна нам
турбот всі ми так вистачає зайвих
комплексів неповноцінності людям не
треба і нащо якщо з кожного продукту по
суті можна зробити
Люкс можна зробити його улюбленцем людей
будьте коледж чи в йогурт неважливо
Головне Головне щоб продукт не боявся
змінюватись і слухав людей
от що ми нереально дивує Так це те що от
якщо креатив дозволяє створити щось з
вакууму коли комунікувати по суті
абсолютно нічого То чому його не
використати для створення якісних
внутрішніх змін в самому продукті щоб
з'явилося що комунікувати
і так це важче Так це енерго і ресурсу
виснажливіше це потребує більше
інтеграції між клієнтською і креативною
командами але тут же вибір між
якимись довгостроковим профітом да після
якого людина потенційно
розчарується не реалізує своїх очікувань
і відмовиться або між
довгостроковим
реально змінами яких генерують
позитивний досвід відкладаються надовго
працюють не на Імідж А на репутацію
власне вашу
От і тут Я б хотів швиденько розглянути
кейс бікерстафа якраз Мені здається Він
дуже чудово Це демонструє є такий бренд
appciple Store ласка е-е
багато хто з вас можливо його знає для
тих хто не знає це
відбірний секонд-хенд якщо так можна
сказати але чудові ребята Чим вони
займаються до них завжди можна принести
свої речі одяг який ти не носиш здати
його Вони його розприділяють по тим кому
цей одяг необхідний а і
якісь круті речі Вони залишають в
магазині виставляють на продаж е-е
продають ці речі із них кошти
направляють на допомогу підтримують кучу
благодійних фондів волонтерських
ініціатив але це створює таку ситуацію в
якій коштів не вистачало для власне
розвитку самої ласки і вони ну ласка
прийшла до бікістафу з початкового з
бажанням зробити якусь donation кампанію
а
на що сказав окер став і зробив Не
данишин компанія новий бізнес-напрям
тобто
вони подумали що люди і багато агентів
агенції брендів а створюють свій мерч
цей мерч Дуже часто закінчує своє життя
якраз на секонд-хендах То навіщо
створювати новий мерч якщо можна взяти
старий переборантувати його і видати як
свій мерч і тепер це не просто якась
надрукована штука з логотипом бренду А
цей ще Ну по суті
джерело інвестицій раз а от для ласки А
по-друге це дуже системі було рішення
тому що ми не створюємо зайвого сміття
зайвого одягу Тобто всі він він ситуації
тобто мова йде про те що замість
комунікації була створена бізнес рішення
яке створило новий потік е-е доходів і
окрім того мала офігенний дуже
піар вихлоп тому що багато людей про це
дізнались і звернули увагу магазин і це
до чого як зробити коледжі
привабливішими залучати креатив не
тільки для створення картинок кислогонів
для вступної кампанії
залучати креатив агенції креативні
агенції до зміни і вдосконалення
коледжів зсередини от до процесів до
покращення існуючих викладацьких
процесів і пошуку нових
бізнес-перспектив і аудиторій
можемо почати з того що встановимо всі
коледжі пандусу і подивимось чи це
робиться їх привабливішим Дякую Дякую
Ну і відчуваю питання про фінансування
да іде якесь це питання всім напруженій
в очікуванні тому що воно має а я думаю
що пан
Петро якраз і Дмитро Господи вибач і
відповість власне у нас залишається не
так багато часу і дуже багато питань
тому я передам тіпа одну штучку просто
про те що не бійтесь Я розумію що всі
коли говорять про креативні агенції всі
відразу дума говорить про бюджет І що це
дорого і тому подібне Не забувайте що це
не єдиний спосіб зараз є дуже багато
креативних волонтерських організацій є
чати в телеграмі там на подобі
креативної Січі постатвертайзінгу Там
дуже багато волонтерів з креативної
індустрії які залюбки допоможуть
чомусь що допоможе країні і не забувайте
про те що ваших е-е учбових закладах
дуже багато людського креативного
потенціалу ви завжди можете залучити
своїх учнів до до створення якихось
прикольних штук а потім просто запросити
наприклад нас чи інших каратищиків для
того щоб ми відфільтрували і допомогли
зробити це ще краще І ви будете
створювати якраз таки учбові заклади до
яких люди будуть відчувати свою
причетність студенти будуть відчувати
свою причетність і таким чином їхня
загальна репутація буде зростати Дуже
дякую Вибачте Дуже дякую
Ну що Дмитро Я думаю що час
підрезимувати а ти як заступник міністра
освіти і науки е-е Я думаю що може дати
таке обрав'ю про те як ми рухаємось до
коледжу в майбутнього Ну і відповідно У
нас уже сформувались такі питання на які
здається потрібно дати відповіді де
хороші і як співпрацювати з бізнесом І
що відбувається з ципровізацією як і зі
способом вирішувати як ці питання так і
покращувати досвід студента
Дякую Ну це прям на годину ти закинув
питань
Давайте почнемо з найважчого
де взяти гроші І що з цим робити потім
друге буде з цим пов'язаним мабуть
у нас зараз в системі освіти більше 600
закладів профтехосвіти 640 ще десь
приблизно коледжів Тобто це майже 1300
закладів
якщо подивитись повернутись до найпершої
презентації яку ми бачили сьогодні І
будувати щось подібне з нуля Ви можете
поїхати в Український Католицький
Університет і побачити подібне ну тобто
що виглядає так як було на презентації
Тобто це можливо навіть Можливо в
Україні і так далі ми їздили дивилися на
ці гуртожитки вони чудові вони продумані
прекрасно зроблені архітектор який
працював над центром Шептицького до
цього робив корпус гарвардського
університету Тобто це можливо і на щастя
це навіть не дуже дорого це тисяча
доларів на квадратний метр те що у них
вийшло в результаті 40 тисяч квадратних
метрів за 40 мільйонів доларів
але повертаючись до тієї кількості про
яку я згадав на початку і кількість
тисяч сотен мільйонів квадратних метрів
які нам потрібно відремонтувати що
повністю перетворити це на систему
коледжів майбутнього нам знадобиться не
один мільярд доларів це треба якби
усвідомити
ніби не так багато але я особисто
впевнений що це не відбудеться наприклад
наступного року або протягом найближчих
двох років та тому що сума просто
колосальна і тому що у нас є інші
потреби і будь-які мільярди які нам
надходять від наших партнерів
розподіляються по наших програмах щось
на школу на укриття на автобуси і потреб
дуже багато і на жаль
ресурсів не так багато Тому треба якби
це усвідомити зі свого боку ми розуміємо
що для того щоб цих ресурсів в
майбутньому ставало більше нам потрібно
не лише як
цитата лоскутним
способом наводити лад але і досягати
якби кінцевої мети кінцевої точки
трансформації хоча б інфраструктурної
щоб ми могли показати а як це взагалі
має виглядати в закінченому вигляді
повністю з класним гуртожитком класними
приміщеннями і так далі для обов'язково
запустився проект по створенню центрів
професійної досконалості які інвестує
європейські інвестиційний банк там і так
далі І тут треба теж зрозуміти у нас
перший Центр професійної досконалості
ось якщо ми з Іриною володимирівною
будемо займатися цим невпинно без
вихідних і так далі запуститься 1
вересня 26-го року тобто будівництво
займає час ми зі свого боку впевнені що
до 1 вересня 26-го або 27-го року
будь-який активний директор не буде
сидіти і чекати поки ж ми дійдемо з
якимись очередним банком до цього
директора і не заплануємо ще на 10 років
якусь трансформацію а буде щось робити
самостійно
і ми дуже-дуже намагаємося щоб у нас
було не лише з державних коштів але і з
донорських коштів програми окремих
модернізації закладів освіти на
обладнання на ще щось на ремонти
гуртожитків і так далі для того щоб ми
могли демонструвати ці зміни і часткові
як ці гроші отримати і Чому хтось
фактично до них там дуже близько я
сподіваюся там цього року на нове
обладнання а хтось від них нескінченно
далеко і не не є в нашому якомусь списку
тих кому хочеться допомогти і чим чим це
відрізняється це як Ключ до успіху Я
вважаю з мого останніх от півроку
спілкування вже точно збільшені
директорів закладів освіти їх відрізняє
енергійність І підприємливість от вона
або є або її немає якщо вона є зазвичай
в заклад вже її на собі відчув Тобто ви
можете побачити результати цих якостей в
цьому закладі освіти це не завжди
означає що наприклад у директора при цих
неймовірних якостях є відчуття смаку або
якісь інші важливі якості але якщо
енергійний підприємець керує ви це точно
можете побачити на закладі він точно
кудись рухається і розвивається
до чого призводить наявність цих якостей
в першу чергу який я от висновок може
зробити з цієї історії до того що
починають залучатися ті хто найближче
всього знаходиться до закладу умовно
якісь цей холдери бенефіціари якщо
наприклад ви бачите закладу освіти і
директор закладу не спілкується з
головою громади якщо це в області це не
підприємливий заклад освіти точно Да
якщо він не співпрацює якось зі школами
де вчаться дев'ятикласники потенційні
здобувачі освіти це не підприємливий
керівник і так далі якщо він не знає
скільки потенційно школярів взагалі його
умовно Маркет кепп Да То це не не
підприємливий керівник але якщо він це
робить і виходить і спілкується завжди
показує шукає точки
такої взаємодії питаю чим ми можемо бути
корисним яку послугу ми можемо вам
надавати і так далі
ви побачите що заклад розвивається
другим етапом як на мене після того як
Цей директор от з усіма поспілкувався і
про взаємодіяв зрозумів взагалі що що
навколо нього знаходиться
є формування спільних проектів
і спільних пропозицій тому що я вам так
скажу от станом на зараз будь-яка
пропозиція яка є спільною важить в
десятеро більше Тобто ви приходите до
Міністерства і кажете Ми хочемо
відремонтувати дах це одна історія або
Там ми хочемо майстерню Ми хочемо там
кухню інша історія ви приходите кажете
дивіться ми тут хочемо кухню Ми
домовились з громадою що ми будемо брати
участь в закупівлях на харчування для
шкіл і садочків всіх громаді громада
якщо ми знайдемо гроші на кухню готова
інвестувати в ремонт там гуртожитку
область готова на 10% до фінансувати
кухню більше грошей немає от проект ось
бюджет і так далі це ну знайти гроші на
таку кухню взагалі не проблема ну
реально всі наші партнери хочуть
вірити в те що ті гроші які вони
вкладають будуть далі жити і розвиватись
що вони не дарують щось Що буде ле На
полиці А що це буде далі мати якийсь
мультиплікаційний ефект чи це буде
використовувалось що це комусь крім вас
двох потрібно того хто хоче завжди там
гроші як ну директор Це просто якби
класична ситуація що ви приходите кажуть
нам щось потрібно це зрозуміло Да але
не за Ну конкурувати треба оцим
залученням тобто залучати інших з
тихходерів до
фінансування тоді Повірте ці гроші буде
набагато більше і їх якби можна залучити
буде набагато більше показуючи приклади
гарних проектів так само це має
мультиплікаційний ефект вам значно легше
на наступних кроках показуючи певну
певну динаміку тому підводячи підсумки
можливо з того що з чого говорили
Сьогодні
мені здається що директор є взагалі
визначальною і такою ключовим елементом
успішності
і тому його точно треба вчити і точно
треба розуміти як знайти оцих енергійних
людей яких можна навчити які можна
показати і так далі друге - це те чому
дуже важко насправді навчити і те що
перетинається з першою презентацією
директорів і тих людей які приймають
рішення і мені здається що і студентів
треба багато возити тому що якщо вони
ніколи не йде не були
Важко уявити як вони мають створити
коледж майбутнього тобто щоб створити
коледж майбутнього ви можете створити
людину яка була в такому місці ну тобто
яка його відвідала відчула
поспілкувалась тоді вона взагалі у неї
бачення от без бачення немає ніякого
шляху Це точно Тобто мають бути
енергійні люди і треба створити їм
сучасне бачення
і далі разом з цими людьми Ми Точно
знайдемо ресурси поступово не якби
миттєво Це точно великий шлях але чим
більше буде з'являтися ну результатів
коли це бачення буде втілено тим більше
ресурсів буде туди додаватися і
додаватися я як би в цьому впевнений
і важливий важливий дуже елемент про
який я забув сказати його можливо не
було в питанні але я дуже хотів Я вважаю
що це елемент назвемо це українських
коледжів майбутнього Миколи порівнюємо
систему професійної освіти степу з
успішними країнами Німеччина Швейцарія і
так далі ми ці приклади на мою думку
можемо натягнути лише на ті заклади у
яких є великі роботодавці наприклад
арселор в Кривому Розі чи
запорожсталь чи атомна електростанція і
так далі В такому випадку ми можемо
казати що тут треба запроваджувати
більше дуальної освіти треба інвестувати
в умовно-навчальні приміщення класні
гуртожитки ну тобто це має бути така
класна Старша школа з практикою на цьому
підприємстві і дуже глибокою взаємодією
але я не уявляю собі умовно до 2030 року
це мабуть наш такий зараз основний
горизонт планування яким чином заклади
які готують для маленького середнього
бізнесу можуть використати оцей
німецький досвід
тому шлях розвитку для цих закладів ви
співпраці з роботодавцями На мою думку
буде базуватися в створенні оцих якісних
навчально-практичних центрів
підприємницького такого спрямування
тобто коли інвестиція в обладнанні цих
центрів
збільшує спеціальний фонд закладу освіти
і На жаль ми розуміємо що
в різних професіях ця інвестиція Вона
нерівномірна має повернення тобто
наприклад закупівля аграрної техніки
повертає набагато більших грошей в
заклад ніж там швейної наприклад хоча
швейної теж нормально ну працює там
кухні працюють можливо от Я наприклад не
впевнений чи столярна майстерня
наприклад який у неї
риторинав-інвестмент але це той Фактор
на який ми будемо дивитись і треба ну
просто дивитись справді вічі що ми
оперуємо дуже маленькими ресурсами Ну
просто смішними тобто якщо от уявимо
собі там остання субвенція на
навчально-практичні центри була
Підкажіть 250 мільйонів 300 млн
250 250 мільйонів на той час 10
мільйонів доларів якщо в Німеччині
сказати ми проінвестували 10 на всю
країну на обладнання і так далі Ну це
просто ну смішно Це дуже маленька
історія тому її треба вкладати там де
вона має от максимальною ефект і На мою
думку максимальний ефект - це
співпраця це там де до цього долучаються
громада і область в даному випадку і т і
інше і друге це там де це має можливості
потім щоб заклад заробляв гроші і за І
от в моїй якби тейсі коледж майбутнього
в Україні коли ж майбутнього 2030 році в
Україні це коледж який вміє заробляти
який вміє себе рекламувати як для
студентів так і вміє з цього надавати
послуги хай це буде 10% 15% від
загального бюджету закладу але заклад
точно може справлятися з поточними
проблемами які в нього виникають такі як
дах
ще щось тобто в коледж майбутнього який
я приїжджаю 2030 році цих проблем немає
тому що заклад може їх вирішити сам і
він показує нові інвестиційні проекти
він каже дивіться Ми хочемо відкрити
нові професії з енергетики нам потрібно
100 тисяч доларів на сонячні панелі на
дах на лабораторію на ще щось ми з цією
компанією готові співпрацювати нам Отакі
капітальні видатки потрібні і ми будемо
далі рухатися і не не має оцих базових
потреб тому що заклад на них вміє
заробляти самостійно і для цього ми
маємо зараз інвестувати от в оце
підприємництво і в теобладнання яке це
дозволить робити Дякую
прошу одне питання
директор не мішаєвського фахового
коледжу альохін Володимирович Пане
Дмитро гроші не прошу хоча тоже надо але
Запрошую в коледж майбутнього на який ми
вже дорозі йдемо знаю вам ще японці
мають мають обладнання я знаю провести
японське
Ну що ж Друзі на цьому
пан Дмитра Дякую завершується наша друга
панель про коледжу майбутнього Зараз
починається найцікавіше обід А власне
15:30 Ми продовжуємо і наступне питання
без запитань скільки плотне запитання
задати в приватному режимі для того щоб
ми встигли трошки відновити сили поїсти
і відпочити
в 15-30 зустрінемось поговорити про
новітні освітні програми і
Побачимось Дякую я ще хотів сказати У
нас є ще колега представник поліцейської
академії якщо хтось не був поліцейській
академії в Києві Я думаю що ви зможете
запросити так само
Так я просто всім раджу тому що для мене
це приклад майбутнього ну тобто це
приклад того от ви можете відвідати щось
І у вас з'явиться бачення тобто
з'явиться приклад того як може виглядати
заклад професійної освіти як він може як
може бути організовані процеси і так
далі Мені здається що треба всім
подорожувати і бачити гарні приклади і
обов'язково до вас теж
Дуже дякую нашим спікерам Дякую вам До
зустрічі 15:30
що система професійної освіти що
Національне агентство кваліфікації
робить робить в напрямку наближати ринок
праці та до підготовки кваліфікованих
робітників ми з вами поговорили про те
Якими мають бути нові сучасні коледжі
закладу освіти як зробити його
привабливим як зробити щоб туди йшли
діти і це було проформу А зараз ми з
вами спробуємо це саме друге питання але
проговорити з позиції змісту та яким
змістом має бути наповнений заклад
освіти для того щоб
для того щоб роботодавець був
задоволеним тим який Робітник на виході
Виходить з того закладу освіти та для
того щоб
діти були задоволені процесом навчання
Ну і про привабливість для того щоб
батьки хотіли віддати своїх дітей в Цей
заклад освіти та і з вашого дозволу я
представлю вам
сьогоднішніх спікерів
в принципі це це якраз задача простіша
трохи тому що від Заходу до заходу там
особливо від автопаті до автопаті після
заходів
спікери потихеньку стають вже бути там
не просто колегами починають бути
друзями і тоді вже на наступних заходах
їх набагато легше представляти
значить з вашого дозволу пані Олена
грішаєва заступниця директора
навчально-методичного центру
профтехосвіти у Дніпропетровській
області
[оплески]
пан Олександр трегуб засновник і сіо та
виконавчий директор це правильно
самий головний директор і співзасновник
projector Creative and Touch online
інститут
пані Ніна Миколаївна іларіонова
експертка Ти вже не експерт Ти вже
керівниця напрямку ціла
експертка швейцарсько-українського
проєкту публічно приватне партнерство
для поліпшення професійної освіти в
Україні якщо по простому то етап
[оплески]
пан Павло кулішенко заступник начальника
академії патрульної поліції
і пан Володимира льохін директор
відокремленого структурного підрозділу
Немішаївський фаховий коледж
Отож колеги
зміст та що в програмах навчальних що на
уроках має бути такого
щоби
освіта професійна освіта в Україні
була престижною бажаною і сучасною
затребуваний на ринку праці Пані Олено
будь ласка вам перше слово
а презентація буде Як тільки ви почнете
говорити це магія
Добре дякую а отже сьогоднішня моя
презентація ви зараз бачите все
нормально ви зараз бачите саме на екрані
назву короткострокова навчання він він
варіант для професійного розвитку
протягом життя коли готувалася то
мовників питала чи то потрібно ставити
той знак питання чи можливо не потрібно
ну сказали не потрібно Нехай хтось Нехай
всі сприймають як як сприймають хтось
сприйме це як той позитив а хтось
сприйметь саме зі знаком питання чи то
буде дійсно за цим майбутнім чи можливо
його не буде ну і можливо в кінці нашої
панелі ви приймете якесь певне рішення
або буде своя певна думка до цього
питання Отже Дійсно я хочу зараз
проговорити саме про короткострокове
навчання і зі сторони позитиву і саме з
сторони тих ризиків або викликів які
можуть стояти Зараз перед освітянами
щодо запровадження їх так ось Що
наприклад у вас ми зараз всі тут
освітяни зібралися і не тільки освітян
Наскільки я розумію Що для вас
короткострокове навчання які от
асоціації перші Які у вас вони виникають
скажіть
короткострокове навчання
швидко здобути професію ще
підвищення кваліфікації так ще що
Ага навички протягом життя Отже дійсно
це так тобто короткострокова навчання на
сьогоднішній день це
те навчання яке дозволяє
здобути якийсь якусь певну
компетентність так за короткий проміжок
часу але зараз я не кажу про сертифікати
Як для мене для педагога то для мене
короткострокове навчання цей обов'язково
отримання сертифікату на перше місце
ставлю а вже потім оту компетентність
але якщо брати робітничу професію то
зрозуміло то компетентність а вже потім
сертифікація і я про той ризик і виклик
в системі визнання буду говорити Вже
наприкінці так ось щодо переваг
короткострокового навчання
Я напевно щось тут у мене не получається
не знаю ладно Отже щодо переваг до
короткострокового навчання то я би
хотіла зауважити що їх декілька ви зараз
їх будете будете бачити на екрані Дякую
ага дякую Ви бачите відразу її навчилися
і то таке Отже це адаптація до змін ну
зрозуміло що нікому з нас зараз не
потрібно доказувати про те що технології
не стоять на місці І ці технології
заставляють нас рухатися вперед нас
освітян для того щоб ми освітні програми
робили такими які які задовольняли на
сьогоднішній день роботодавця і ті
короткострокові програми могли би стати
отим інструментом для того щоб
в кінцевому варіанті людина яка буде
працювати або працює і займається
своєю освітою в тому числі і
короткостроковим навчанням здобуває ті
навички які дадуть їй право і
конкурентноспроможність на тому робочому
місці на своєму підприємстві або навіть
більше таке навчальне дійсно надає на
сьогоднішній день швидкі і позитивні
результати які можуть мотивувати людину
до подальшого розвитку Ну якщо мені 40+,
Наприклад і я хочу
сказала 40+ І якщо я хочу на
сьогоднішній день щоб навчитися
наприклад іноземній мові Я розумію що це
довгий процес і мене цей процес стримує
а от якщо ви я знала що я навчусь варити
борщ для того щоб чоловік мене не вигнав
з дому Да то я напевно швиденько піду
навчуся і то буде короткострокове
навчання і я матиму змогу дійсно бути
там корисною чи мати змогу
далі ті знання вміння навички
застосовувати і ця швидка мотивація
вірніше ця швидка це швидке навчання
воно мотивує людину далі якщо це дійсно
панування пройшло позитивно то далі це
призведе до того що людина буде І далі
займатися впродовж життя отримує
навчанням тобто не буде такої
перестороги для неї що є якийсь страх
перед віком і я далі не навчаюся
короткострокові програми також надають
майже можливість
зосередитися На конкретних навичках і ці
конкретні навички вони роблять навчання
більше ефективним і більш доступним
деякі люди вони взагалі можливо не в
змозі опановувати довгострокові програми
і от е-е це може бути таке якби два
фактори це може бути Фактор часу тобто
немає часу на те що буде довгострокова
навчатися і другий момент - це все-таки
фінансові затрати і Отже в на даний етап
часу короткострокове навчання може
вирішувати цю проблему
також і не можу не сказати про гнучкість
вибору Тому що замовник а замовником
може бути як роботодавець так і просто
пересічний громадянин він під себе
замовляє отой Результат навчання ви
зараз почули те словосполучення
Результат навчання Да який йому потрібен
для того щоб бути більш
востреба вони Вибачте на слові да так
так
затребуваним
під роботодавця чи
для самого себе Отже
в тих сах позитивах є і певні ризики або
виклики сьогодні сіла в потяг і думаю
напевно назвали неправильно напевно не
ризики а виклики і перед системою в тому
перед системою освіти в тому числі
тому прагненні якби швидко підготувати
швидко підготувати слухача
було певно до певних вимог роботодавця У
нас є на сьогоднішній день така
пересторога вони достатній підготовці
виконувати якісь певні виклики на
робочому місці І це дійсно є і з нашого
досвіду роботи я можу це підтвердити
також короткострокові програми вже
сьогодні було дуже багато сказано про
розвиток сосків слів короткострокові
програми вони на сьогоднішній день ми
все-таки більше зупиняємося на хардкілах
і в нас немає часу на те щоб розвивати
їх совскіли і Але в цьому є і вихід
Тобто ми можемо пропонувати наприклад
окремі програми для розвитку собскелів
для того щоб та людина чи той
чи той роботодавці роботодавець був
задоволений також корисний
короткострокові програми вони можуть
потребувати від здобувачів освіти
високого рівня самостійності ми робили
такий експеримент Коли у нас було
декілька груп і ці групи окремо йшли
одні по офлайн формі а інші йшли по
змішаній формі і ось тут така ділема у
нас виникла ми спеціально це зробили Для
чого Для того щоб подивитися на якість
освітньої послуги в кінцевому варіанті І
що ми замітили значить ті хто навчався
на формі офлайну у них теоретичні знання
якість теоретичних знань вона була
більша ніж у тих хто займався самостійно
і коли ми робили опитування то вони саме
казали про те що у них є проблема з
таймінгуванням часу для підготовки до
занять і тут ми бачили декілька проблем
це перша мотивація тої групи щоби дійсно
люди вчасно це робили і якісно це робили
і другий момент - це те що ми коли
напрацьовували теоретичний матеріал ми
робили великою базою тобто тема вона
була велика а потім ми прийшли до
висновку що потрібно робити невеликими
порціями той теоретичний матеріал для
того щоб
людина відразу фідбек ставили контрольні
завдання і людина відразу фідбек
відчувала від того що ж вона на
сьогоднішній день знає для того щоб
потім відкоригувати свої знання тобто
тут ще дидактичний аспект Ну і бачите по
ризикам два останніх ризики особливо
мене турбує це не готовність
педагогічних колективів запроваджувати
це короткострокове навчання
повинна знаєте як На мою думку це моя
особиста думка повинна прийти та зміна
стереотипу що ми можемо навчати лише за
довгостро програмами
в закладі професійно-технічної освіти
всі повинні розуміти весь колектив що
заклад освіти він повинен бути
економічно продуктивним і економічна
продуктивність Вона може досягатися саме
за рахунок
освітніх послуг
великої кількості освітніх послуг і ті
освітні послуги вони можуть бути
різнобічними головне знайти в собі сили
розробляти це і ще один от саме в цьому
в цій неготовності є те що педагогічні
колективи не готові розробляти якісні
освітні програми з досвіду роботи знову
ж таки кажу ми завжди як педагоги
намагаємося дуже багато надавати
матеріалу і вбачаємо в тому Чим більше
ми дамо тим краще у нас вийде результат
Ну насправді то не так і ось те що ми
робили були певні засідання Ми наприклад
напрацювали освітню програму і вона
підрезультат навчання так як повинно
бути що вимагає на сьогоднішній день
роботодавець але от В кінцевому варіанті
що ми мали ми мали програму на сім на
вісім тижнів 7-8 тижнів
короткостроковому навчанні це забагато
Отже що ми робили далі ми всі
оговтувалися я збирала знову творчу
групу і після тої творчої групи яка
казала ціль така Результат навчання
звучить Ось так давайте будемо визначати
от той теоретичний матеріал або
практичний матеріал він на сьогоднішній
день потрібен для того щоб формувати цей
Результат навчання і ми відшліфовували і
виходили вже не 7-8 тижнів тижнів а
виходили на 3-4 тижні Отже такий досвід
є і в тому є зараз потреба робити
методичних служб на те що ми
напрацьовуємо інструментарій для того
щоб якісно і правильно формувати оці
результати навчання Ну і сніданок це
питання визнання питання визнання До
речі
дійсно деякі короткі курси вони не мають
повної ваги на ринку праці Оте що я
казала ми правильно повинні формувати
назву результату навчання не може бути
Результат навчання наприклад
приготування пісочного тіста
повинен бути Коннект між роботодавцем
закладом професійної освіти і можливо
тим хто на сьогоднішній день то послугу
буде отримувати Для чого Для того щоб
визначити оту золоту серединку і
визначитись тим що ж на кінцевому
варіанті потрібно оце Ну той залог коли
ми в паритеті возьмемо оці позитиви як
про які і казала і про ці ризики які
тільки що озвучила Тому Дякую вам за
увагу Якщо у вас є якісь інші думки
ну
і мене звати Сергій директор профтеху я
хочу сказати Я зараз беру участь у
програмі єразмус плюс по розробці оце
безпосередньо проект вем Хто знає хто
долучається да знають то зараз іде саме
безпосередньо створення цих
мікрокваліфікацій мікрокредитів
називають і якщо підприємство ви
правильно сказали Якщо підприємство не
зацікавлене ми можемо собі повидумувать
все що завгодно але їх ніхто не візьме
на роботу Вони не будуть визнані от надо
з підприємствами повністю заключати
договір те що от це це дуже важливо Це
питання що ми не можемо собі понабирати
і готувати людей в нікуди це надо тільки
обов'язково погоджуватись підприємствами
роботодавці
дякую дякую
знаю точно що весь процес та ну ви ж
знаєте є програма після нашої панелі ще
там церемонія нагородження і так далі
знаю точно що весь процес трошки
затримується і у нас буде трошки більше
часу на дискусії але точно не знаю
наскільки тому от сам до пані Олени
виписав запитання он Але зараз не
задаватиму давайте ми послухаємо
доповіді та послухаємо може між собою
між собою Наші спікери десь не зовсім
будуть погоджуватись назбираємо собі
запитання і спробуємо Ну я для себе
записую от можете робити так само як я
та А зараз я би до слова хотів запросити
пана Володимира
пане Володимир навіть заступника
міністра запрошував до себе в заклад
казав що Подивіться як у нас приїдьте ми
вже буду новітні заклади освіти і
зокрема у вас є концепція мережевої
взаємодії Здається так правда Ось будь
ласка розкажіть колегам Можливо вони
щось для себе візьмуть корисно з цього
Дякую
Шановні колеги Звичайно хотілося б
розказати і про те як покращували
матеріальну базу коли викладачі
працівники скидалися на те щоб дах
поміняти на одному корпусі хотілося б
розказати як були і е-е під час окупації
А ми за 7 км від Бучі І що після того як
відновлювалися Звичайно хотілося б
розказати багато і за те що як ми в
цьому році 600 студентів прийняли на
навчання і 1800 студентів зараз маємо як
колектив працює багато чого потрібно але
Враховуючи те що от з самого початку і
віце-прем'єр і міністр говорили що в нас
єдине повинно бути направлення від
дошкільнят до працездатного і якщо ми
залишимося так як завжди зараз кожна
локація відпрацьовує свій напрямок то
звичайно в нас нічого не вийде що
сьогодні відбувається Ми один з одним
конкуруємо і на превеликий жаль Ми
створюємо прецедент зараз що робити далі
ми розмежовані якщо говорити зараз
розглянувши навчальні заклади чи це буде
коледж чи професійна освіта е-е в
системі нуш нової української школи що
ми бачимо ми бачимо що на сьогоднішній
день ми повинні думати що нам робити
буде створено міністерством сьогодні е-е
під база щоб профільна Школа була
розташована на опорній школі чи десь в
якоїсь школі чи використана буде База та
що створена вже багатьма роками і вона
буде використана для направлення на
профільній освіті Звичайно Це питання
турбує всіх і Саме тут доцільно
розглядати чи це буде фаховий коледж чи
це буде інший Напрямок в реалізації
третього рівня
нуш звичайно це повинно може бути і як
мережева взаємодія між суб'єктами
соціального партнерства і фаховий коледж
це і ресурсний центр якраз на його базі
де є всі гуртожиток із усе вдосконалити
і це можна було би робити дуже здорово
які переваги це економія коштів це
використання тієї бази яка єсть і це
швидше Можна було б започаткувати для
конкретної роботи Якщо взяти по
координації мережевої взаємодії то
Міністерство освіти є унікальна
структура Міністерства освіти і науки
України це науково-методичний центр
вищої та фахової передвищої освіти ним
керує Іщенко Тетяна Дем'янівна що
забезпечив би реалізацію наукового
навчально-методичного супроводу
інформаційного забезпечення освітньої
діяльності та сприятиме інтеграція
Освіти і Науки до Світового освітнього
Профі простору тому що там дуже багато є
вже напрацьованих проектів і роль
фахового коледжу на орбіті вищої освіти
так ось це центр практично орієнтованого
навчання
створення філіалів закладів вищої освіти
на базі коледжів і можуть зробити освіту
більш доступною на територіальному рівні
чому необхідно зберегти
освітньо-професійний рівень молодшого
бакалавра фахового молодшого бакалавра
якщо взяти нині кожне
технологічне підприємство кількість
зайнятих працівників то в основному
зараз
працедавцям потрібен мобільний та
поліфункціональний працівник і ось тут
якщо говорити хто може бути таким
працівником звичайно Магістр але це 5
років навчання звичайно бакалавр але це
4 роки навчання А от фаховий молодший
бакалав 2-2,5 роки після того коли він
матиме вже
середню освіту і таким чином можуть
найбільш доступно поступити на ринок
праці Отже фахової молодший бакалавр
фахівець із знанням інженера і
практичними навиками кваліфікованого
робітника зараз дуже серйозні стоять
завдання перед
коледжами де
необхідно шукати шляхи ефективного
ефективної підготовки майбутніх фахівців
і звичайно тут ми повинні говорити про
дуальну освіту як максимум це за
елементи дуальної освіти що необхідно
зробити і тоді це буде покращення і
опп навчальних програм і інші
направлення коли співпрацювати і з
роботодавцем якщо говорити за
роботодавців і фаховий коледж і
роботодавці то дуже серйозно про це
можна говорити у сфері того що як зараз
роботодавець працює сьогодні не просто
так що приходить Дайте мені студента
який буде в нас працювати роботодавець
який веде з другого з третього курсу
студента і він запрошує його на практику
Тоді це буде нормально Але що ми
сьогодні маємо якщо один студент
проходить практику навчальну практику
механіка наприклад десь у гаражі чи на
сто невеликому а другий проходе на е-е
заводі Антонова умовно і тоїсть і той
проходять практику але диплом то один і
кожний задоволений так ось нам треба
зараз узагальнити для того щоб ми могли
зробити щоб база навчального закладу чи
це буде коледж чи професійної освіти
якраз відповідатиме тому рівню який
необхідно щоб зробити
мотивованим і роботодавця і фахівця і
всіх хто цим займається щоб було
ефективно
не мішаєвський коледж є структурним
підрозділом національного університету
для ресурсів природокористування України
Дехто каже треба вивести із системи тому
що це залежність чи незалежність ні
Навпаки це є і база практики Для певних
навчальних закладів вищої освіти і в той
же час наша ланка бачить що робиться
вище освіти і це не просто що студентів
тут загнали ні зараз Цього вже не
відбувається Навпаки ще більше могли
вимоги створюються для цього направлення
і Якщо говорити що е-е створення цих
центрів То
якраз коледж і могли би бути такими
центрами
доцільно говорити про
наступне по аналогії закладами
профільної освіти можливо і зробити
треба що по аналогії що єсть академічний
бакалавр і профільний бакалав
академічний бакалав освіта здобувається
в університеті
теоретично-методично Наукова діяльність
підготовка частка практичної складової
до 50% і конкурсний вступ до
магістратури а з професійний бакалав тут
уже освіта здобувається в коледжі
практику орієнтована підготовка частка
практичної складової 60-70% і конкурсний
вступ Якщо хоче далі йти до магістратури
плюс ЗНО плюс стаж роботи не менше років
тоді це було би доцільно і правильно і
Якщо говорити що
коледжі На що вони здатні то вони здатні
набагато більше у нас 11 спеціальності
ми в основному аграрно направлення маєм
так ось якщо говорити земля і заклади
освіти для закладів аграрного
спрямування земля необхідна тому що там
проходять практику і механіки агрономи і
технології тому що немішаївському
коледжі є понад 600 гектарів орної землі
є більше 200 голів великої рота І худоби
машина тракторний парк зооцентр і інші
направлення в лабораторії тому прикладом
сьогодні е-е співпраці повинно бути
робота з роботодавцями і е-е державна
приватними партнерство в цьому році
підприємство каргіл яке відоме на
Україні зробило побували в нас побачили
що ми щось робимо і тільки в цьому році
вони започаткували три лабораторії
це ветеринарна медична клініка півтора
мільйона два з половиною мільйона
безпека харчових продуктів і зараз
завершується третя лабораторія практично
6 млн це відновлювана енергетика сонячні
панелі і ми не кажемо сьогодні що тільки
з держави гроші це повинно бути і
державне е-е партнерство з бізнесом і
роботи звичайно пріоритетом держави
повинно бути підготовка фахового е-е
студента і готувати правильно ви кажете
що треба готувати на коротку термінових
курси чим Ми займаємося і в цілому
звичайно сьогодні хочеться подякувати
міністерству і всім рівнем влади і
депутатам тих рівнів які допомагають тим
колективам де розвивається і працюють не
мішаєвський коледж готовий до реформ і
Запрошуємо всіх гості до нас будь ласка
приїжджайте Дякую за увагу
Ну багато Да типу в мене склалось Ну ви
прямо так от
хотів да да
ну менше з тим У мене все рівно будуть
практичні питання до вас пізніше так як
ми домовлялись в залежності від того що
нам з часом
давайте У Ніни Миколаївна запитаємо
ваш досвід в
цей мікрофончик
в той мікрофончик говорити не треба
Якщо я правильно розумію у вас є
унікальний досвід підвищення
кваліфікації педагогів в закладах
професійної освіти Давай про цю про це
ми ще сьогодні не говорили будь ласка
Я вважаю модель
навчально-практичних конференцій які ми
проводимо для наших майстрів виробничого
навчання і для
педагогів для викладачів
в чому основна ідея коли ми говоримо про
те що ринок наші випускники мають
виходити на ринок праці і бути готові до
мати ті навички ті скіли які потребує
ринок праці ми десь забуваємо про те що
хтось їх повинен цьому навчити і коли ми
кажемо що ринок праці швидкозмінний Ми
тоже забуваємо про те що ми пропускаємо
оцей кусочок хто їх буде вчити цим
швидкозмінним змінам швидкоплинним
змінам і
на щастя на щастя наш проект до цих пір
працював тільки з монтажником
синтех-системі устаткування в результаті
вона склався величезний пол виробників
цього обладнання і достатньо велика
кількість майстрів інсталяторів
практикуючих як вигляд і основна ідея
цих всіх конференцій полягає в
наступному зменшити бар'єри між
виробником інсталятором і системою
освітою для того щоб вони познайомились
для того щоб наші педагоги могли
використовувати могли вчити наших
здобувачів Саме так як цього вимагає
бізнес як це відбувається насправді в
бізнесі а не те як це написано в книжці
чи не так як це написано у відео тому ми
звертаємо уваги не тільки на хардову До
речі складову але і на софт скіли
як це все виглядає насправді
від 10+ компаній виробників привозять на
одну локацію свої
прилади пристрої і насправді це якраз
мова йде про те Які результати навчання
Ми хочемо побачити тому що коли ми
звертаємося до виробників і показуємо їм
професійний стандарт і освітній стандарт
і вони кажуть оце завершена операція оце
завершена операція оце завершена
операція ми привеземо вам обладнані На
ось цю завершену операцію і пропрацюємо
з вашими майстрами саме оцю завершену
операцію насправді вона дійсно коротка
Це дійсно мікрокваліфікація тому що на
одне заняття на один блок іде Ну десь
приблизно від 20 до 40 хвилин тобто це
справді невеличкий кусочок Отже В нас 10
плюс компанія як правило Вони
приїжджають на 2-3 дні в залежності від
ситуації Ми запрошуємо 35 плюс наших
майстрів і викладачів з наших проектних
закладів і Ми запрошуємо 4 + 4 5 6 як
получається майстрів інсталяторів які
безпосередньо щодня працюють саме з цим
обладнанням в результаті що получається
в нас є 4-5 локацій на цих
чотирьох-п'яти локаціях постійно отак от
крутячись проходять всі наші учасники як
це відбувається спочатку представник
виробника розказує трішки теорії тобто
чому саме таке обладнання не рекламуючи
власне своє обладнання а пояснюючи
принцип його роботи тому що коли ви
крутите гайки Ви маєте розуміти а чому
це саме Так відбувається це невеликий
кусок теорії Але тут ми наголошуємо і на
енергоефективності і на ефективності в
цілому на швидкості на
ергономічності Саме те що сьогодні
потребує ринок праці Саме те що
потребують кінцеві клієнти
після цього група в 5-6 чоловік
учасників безпосередньо починає
виконувати це завдання під наглядом із
за допомогою того майстра інсталятора
який це показує як це робити
чином в нас станом на сьогодні ми вже
пройшли понад половину освітнього
стандарту по сантехнікам в нас відбулося
таких 4 конференції в чому унікальність
цих конференції виробники дійсно
проводять своє реальне сучасне
обладнання останніх останніх приклад -
це просто унікальний приклад коли
привезли твердопаливний котел
250-кілограмовий і в його спустили в
укриття тому що один з принципів цих
конференцій особливо і в умовах відома
їх проводили і зараз під час ми війни ми
їх проводимо питання безпеки останні
конференція ми просто їх проводимо у
таких підвальних приміщеннях де є для
цього можливість цей твердопаливний
котел спустили вниз і його підключали
буквально підключали при цьому наверху
викопали траншею і там прокладали труби
тому що конференція в нас була опалення
вона була тематична це ми прийшли до
цього до такої моделі от якраз завдяки
тому що ми 4 конференції провели були
трошки інші підходи ми б давали більше
теорії ми ділилидачів і майстрів окремо
на різні групи Але зрозуміло що їх Вони
повинні бути разом вони всі повинні чути
оцей кусочок теорії і викладачі так само
мають вміти крутити ті гайки Вони мають
розуміти про що вони розказують на
теорії і буквально декілька з цифр з
останнього того що ми отримали
це факти за 4 конференції понад 150
учасників понад 20 компаній понад 50
годин теорії понад 150 годин практики
55% стандарту 96% рівень задоволення
крім того що
наші учасники це все пробують зробити
вживу всі залишки звичайно ж таки які
привозяться вони йдуть в училище багато
і не тільки залишків а саме обладнання
достатньо дорогого воно розігрується між
учасниками і вона йде в заклади як для
того щоб
використовувати їх висвітньому процесі і
там де є можливість ми готуємо
відеозапис того що відбувалося особливо
там де є теоретична частина там де це
зручно робити відеозапис тому що коли
стоїть 5-6 чоловік і це робить руками
відеозапис можна зробити але це скоріше
в режимі репортажу а не навчальне відео
воно не інформативне А якраз лекційний
матеріал є плюс е-е методичні посібники
які по цьому тексту готуються це все
викладено в нас на сайті це те Чим
можуть користуватися взагалі все
викладачі всі майстри виробничого
навчання які є в нас в Україні і остання
- це 96% задоволення наших учасників це
вони хочуть вони їздять хто я бачу
багато представників з нмспто Можливо ви
спілкувалися з нашими майстрами вони Вам
тоже розказують Це дійсно ефективно для
них це настільки поштов
розвиватися от для них це поштовх в щось
читати з самим щось вчитися новому не
приїжджають з очима який горять вони це
все показують розказують дітям і вони
при цьому вчаться як
працювати з клієнтами як розмовляти з
майстрами Чому такі наголоси ставити чи
інші наголо си ставити які секретики є у
практикуючих майстрів які вони так само
можуть передати своїм здобувачам освіти
тому ми пропонуємо таку модель і не
тільки для сантехніки тому що воно
реально працює особливо зараз так камінь
в город вищій освіті всі конференції
вищої освіти які називаються
науково-практичні там практичності отак
от науки ось так в нас це перш за все це
практична складова
і як проект ми будемо це продовжувати і
готові ділитися
тими ризиками які ми бачимо
тими нашими помилками щоб уникали таких
помилок і це знову ж таки дозволяє
працювати із бізнесом і з викладачами і
з
і управліннями освіти для того щоб
зменшити розрив у поняттях чого готувати
дякую
Дякую
до вас питання Я до професіонала своєї
справи Ну насправді було вам який
мікрофон більше подобається з червоним
ким чи зелененьким але з цим ви вже
справились добре тоді
друге питання
ваш ну тема вашої розповіді та зміст
професійної освіти від вчора аж до
завтра будь ласка про практичні кейси з
вашого досвіду якщо можна Доброго дня ще
раз Шановні колеги ради вас вітати
як пан Дмитро мене представив і така
грозна назва академія патрульної поліції
Да але тут є два нюанси Я не
поліцейський я викладач я
педагог я освітянин і друга складова -
це ми дійсно протисвітам ми надаємо
професію поліцейські
Вона має свій стандарт освітній і я хочу
сьогодні поговорити саме про зміст
ведучого градус сьогодні розпочати Я
хотів би з Ось чого
Ось так виглядав телефон перший який
з'явився більше ніж сотні років тому
Ну по суті нічого такого там цікавого
Немає да Всі ми знаємо як це виглядало
як воно працювало далі ми на час це
більш вже знайома нам річ да тому що всі
у нас в хаті стояв такий в прихожій десь
там на полички стояв такий телефончик
зізнав як він працює далі знову
технології пішли покрокували вперед і
може сьогодні не уявляємо що телефон
може виглядати якось по-іншому ніж На
цьому малюнку правда ж Ви давайте
реагуйте якось то ви сидите вже аж
засинаєте я бачу реагуйте або киваєте
або піднімайте руки
давайте більш технологічне щось візьмемо
А
давайте візьмемо автомобіль і так
автомобіль Сто років тому Ось він так
виглядав Да такий собі не чути мене
Кажуть не чути
показують що не чути
вже чути чути Да дякую знову технології
змінювались знову
пройшло там 50 років 60-70 і вже
автомобіль виглядав Ось так ну і важко
зараз уявити автомобіль да який може
бути відрізнятися від цього Ну а тепер
Давайте до нашої освіти
Ось так виглядала освітній клас виглядав
Ну десь 100 років тому звичайно лекція
да звичайно там університет коледж
інститутам і так далі
Ось так він виглядав 50 років назад
Ось так він виглядає сьогодні
тобто Світ змінюється колеги змінюється
Світ змінюється міняються люди міняються
технології міняються процеси а наша з
вами освіта на жаль стоїть А якраз таки
на Учора ми цього не помічаємо з вами
Насправді я залишу цей слайд вам на
згадку щоб ви до кінця моєї проповіді
пам'ятали про це
зміст зміст На мою думку це дуже глибоке
поняття дуже глибоке починається воно
дійсно знаєте з чого як театр з вішалки
да так і середовище закладу освіти яке
теж виховує формує навчає і кольористика
як на яку ми не звертаємо уваги кольори
стикає те що в нас на стелі те що у нас
на стінах те що в нас на підлозі друге
складова ви скажете викладач да викладач
абсолютно правильно вчитель викладач
який а сьогодні реалізує наш зміст а-а
наших стандартів і так далі І це
викладач от в мене в моєму форматі моїй
академії патрульної поліції це всі
поліцейські
один юрист там можливо один психолог А
то всі поліцейські Як ви думаєте Мені
освітянино дуже легко з ними
[музика]
Мені дуже легко з ними Як ви думаєте
ні але ні вообще не легко а слова совсем
але в мене є команда освітян я освітянин
я очолив процес освітній процес в
академії в 2017 році і
це була не легкі легкі 6 років тому що
переді мною постала задача а
трансформувати освітній процес
підготовки поліцейських зробити так щоб
це була нова філософія підготовки
поліцейських щоб Це були нові формати
підготовки поліцейських і на цьому етапі
Мені дуже повезли з керівником ми їм він
Кстаті поліцейський
і він якраз таки запровадив дуже цікаву
систему цінностей А це те що говорив
Дмитро Чому він вас запрошує до нас
сказав що ви до нас приїхали не тільки в
нас гарні ремонти гра гарне обладнання і
так далі ще й нас
надзвичайна система цінностей система
мотивації тих людей які приходять
навчатися і працювати в академі
патрульної поліції От тепер до змісту
навчання чого ж ми навчаємо по факту в
мене склалося так що в моєму закладі це
дуже крута система тому що яка сказав В
мене є поліцейські які знають чого треба
навчати і є освітяни які знають як це
зробити щоб навчити і оцей синтез знаю
які знаю чому дає отой результат про
який ми яким ми сьогодні пишаємось
наш виклик номер один - це професія
поліцейського дається Як ви думаєте за
скільки часу
за шість місяців я не знаю це
мікронавчання чи ні чи ще ні чи вже ні
за шість місяців Як ви думаєте який
обсяг в цій 6 місяців годинах
1102 години знаєте яке навантаження
слухача на тиждень
46 годин
у викладача знаєте скільки навантаження
на тиждень
46 годин і це в аудиторії
розумієте да тобто не ставка ставки не
має такого поняття в нас в нас є ставка
немає ставки ніж є оплата з фіксована
зарплата незалежно від того скільки тих
годин викладаєш Ти отримуєш фіксовану
зарплату легко мені Як ви думаєте
реалізувати зміст освіти
І от при всіх цих нюансах які я вам
розповідаю
є була дуже важлива складова з'явився
стандарт професії поліцейські яку треба
було яку треба було щось з нею робити ми
з вами кажемо про те що в нас на кожному
кроці кричимо на стандарти на
компетентність тому підході колеги Але ж
ми не компетентності формуємо з вами Ну
давайте відверто це визнавати ми з вами
навчаємо предметам
ну предметами навчаємо некомпетентностям
тому що ці компетентності формуються
може як одна компетенція дійсно можна
сформувати на одному предметі А є
компетентності які сукупність декількох
предметів далі в мене завжди питання от
до Міністерства освіти наприклад чому ми
в дипломі в додатку до диплома ставимо
оцінку ну условно зараз скажи ніколи не
ображаючим предмет матеріалознавства 5
балів от про що воно сказали роботодавцю
Ані про що
підніміть будь ласка руку з присутніх
тут хто з ваших роботодавців дивився ваш
диплом що там написано в додатку які
оцінки які предмети дивіться жодної одна
Я вас вітаю Ви мабуть єдиного людина в
Україні Яка от дві Вибачте непоміт дві
Ага
розумієте На мою думку якщо ми говоримо
вже про компетентності і є стандарт Де
написано чого ми маємо навчити того чи
іншого фахівця то в нашому випадку ми
маємо роботодавцю написати що він знає з
цього стандарту На якому рівні це Та ж
сама оцінка На якому рівні що він вміє І
тоді робити давить буде розуміти
чого його довчити треба на який процес
його Краще поставити дати йому
наставника чи сказати Вибачте ви нам не
підходите чи можливо дати якусь розумну
книжку почитати розумієте тому оце дуже
важлива складова от ми я вам розповідаю
це я доходжу до того що я буду говорити
вам яка ж фішка ідея моєї академії
Це ті проблемні виклики з якими ми
працювали і не могли зрозуміти як їх
побороти і подолати ми знайшли вихід
Ми прибрали всі до речі за скільки
предметів Як ви думаєте в патрульного
поліцейського навчальному плані
скільки 5
хто більше
39 предметів за шість місяців і за ці 6
місяців кожен предмет закінчується
заліком і екзаменом диференційованим
Ми прибрали 339 предметів ми їх
інтегрували в один предмет але зробили
ще 5 предметів тобто 35 ми інтегрували а
5 лишили для так би мовити об'єднання
всіх інших предметів для оцінок по колу
розмістили 35 предметів Нам вдалося
інтегрувати в один предмет і от тут
якраз таки я вам розкажу В чому суть
цього підходу наприклад є
дорожньо-транспортна пригода і раніше як
його вчили от все Що має знати
поліцейські подружньо-транспортний
пригоді п'ять предметів правила
дорожнього руху предмет називається
оформлення дорожньо-транспортної пригоди
третій предмет порядок складання
адміністративних матеріалів за порушення
правил дорожнього руху і так далі і тому
подібне тепер ми вчимо не так ми вчимо
по-іншому ми беремо конкретно
дорожньо-транспортну пригоду все що
треба саме під цю дорожньо-транспортну
пригоду знати з адміністративного права
зі складання документів що конкретно під
цю дорожньо-транспортну пригоду треба
знати з домедичної підготовки з
тактичної підготовки можливо з вогневої
підготовки і так далі і тому подібне і
таким чином формуємо алгоритми
діяльності в різних ситуаціях службової
діяльності
Цей підхід
дав нам знаєте яку якість на виході на
40% підвищилась якість
результатів навчання на 40%
тобто по суті не було теоретичної
підготовки все було в ході практичної
діяльності тому я вважаю що зміст нашої
професійної освіти це а
середовище; б - це компетентність і
підхід саме а не предметний тому що Марі
Іванівні треба Вибачте якщо тут є
маріванна маріванов мені треба ставку
зробити годинний дати і в - це система
цінностей
і система мотивації всередині закладу От
коли ми ці три шари перекриємо між собою
от тоді ми знаєте що здобудемо оце
от моєму розумінні оце буде наш коледж
майбутнього коли комфортно і цікаво буде
не тільки дітям які до нас приходять
навчатися і дорослим теж А і нам з вами
буде цікаво працювати От коли нам буде з
вами цікаво працювати Повірте це буде
Хогвартс
і кожен з нас буде там Гаррі Поттером
Дякую за увагу
ну підніміть будь ласка руки керівники
закладів
керівники закладів руки підніміть О бачу
там трошки бачу признайтесь чесно кому
захотілось такого заступника зі змісту
освіти
Я дуже дорого коштує Я знаю
але разом Але разом з тим я так трошки
заспийю Та от у нас щойно побачив а між
іншим он він стоїть наша заступник
Дмитро Павло вже про це говорив
всередині вересня приблизно так давайте
діти колеги ми я дійсно співпрацюю за
міністерством освіти Ну так сталося
просто Спочатку це була Ірина
Володимирівна ми з нею задружилися а
потім ще виявилася поки їм Пока Вона не
чує потім ще виявилося що ми сусіди і
через дорогу один від одного мешкає і
потім вже от Льоша став другом великим
пан Дмитро наш заступник Міністра Я вас
всіх запрошую прийдіть подивіться я мої
Двері завжди відкриті в академії в мене
а-а Наша команда колег мій керівник ми
завжди відкриті до діалогів до просто
приїхати на каву заїхати можуть до речі
є такі викладачі і колеги директори
заступники які Просто ви на місці Можна
до вас на каву можна приїжджайте ми
говоримо зі всіма
так от в вересні друга половина вересня
Ми плануємо Дмитро зробив таку заявку
провести семінар на базі академії для
керівників тільки для керівників
закладів освіти професійної освіти Я не
знаю про що ще тему не знаю Це вчора
ввечері Ми домовились що таке семінар
буде І це буде в другій половині вересня
будь ласка Welcome
в нас кожного місяця набір ще одна одним
виклик кожного місяця в мене 1 березня і
кожна місяця в мене останній дзвоник
тому випуск кожного місяця найближчі 22
вересня то я вас запрошую вже тому що цю
дату Я знаю можете прийти подивитись їм
45 хвилин триває в нього чоткий алгоритм
чіткий стандарт тому якщо будете в місті
Києві то белкам дякую
ще раз
Олександра І нарешті як цей хедлайнер
нашого фестивалю занимательных історій
Дякую не думаю все хедлайнер тому що те
як пан Павло Мені не треба дякую все
сформулював навіть не знаю що додати а
єдиний я би попросив А можна вивести
презентацію п Павленко хочу скористатись
на слайді де три телефони були а я зараз
їх використаю якщо ви не проти
зараз зараз буде попробувати Так
попередня презентація три телефони добре
друзі тоді я почну трошечки поясню хто я
що я тут роблю Я є співзасновником
інституту прожектор ви можливо бачили от
в місті синя реклама висить оце ми
висимо projector вивчаємо багато прямо
багато просто щоб було досить
звідки гроші це все до пана Дмитра ну
правда не в нашому випадку це в вашому
випадку
і так само я співзасновник фундації
прожектора яка допомагає міністерству
реформувати систему профтехосвіти
роблячи є більш креативною підприємливою
і сучасною
ще нічого не сказав вже аплодисменти
власне до того як я зайнявся освітою а-а
я був дизайн дизайнером А якщо бачите
там логотип Міністерства освіти багато
страждальної то це я його робив власне
ми в інституті прожектор займаємось
різними такими проектами і я хочу вам
розказати про таку річ от як дизайнер я
почавши займатись викладанням Я зрозумів
що дуже прикро що в освіті дизайн
підходить не використовується от давайте
подивимось на ці телефони
вони насправді зручні по-різному а до
речі цікаво які з цих телефонів на
картинці вам видається найзручнішим
перший середній Ага А чому
Окей просто Та що в центрі
Як створюються телефони
інтерфейси для телефонів предмет стільці
на яких ми сидимо є дизайнерські
метадології от Якщо так грубо сказати є
таке поняття дизайн-мислення або трошки
складніше слово Human сенсор дизайн в
перекладі цей Human центр дизайнер
означає людина в центрі процесу
те про що Павло говорив щойно я так
спробую інтерпретувати як я його відчув
це говорить про наступне в центрі
знаходиться уваги не заклад не процеси
які Цей заклад будує не Міністерство
освіти в центрі стоїть людина яка хоче
стати поліцейським
і Наша задача
подумати спитати зрозуміти а що це за
людина а чого вона хоче І як ми можемо
її допомогти
А наприклад Коли я навчався в
університеті мене жодного разу не
спитали Хто ти чого тобі цікаво і як ми
тобі можемо допомогти я просто опинився
всередині такої системи яка мене
проводила від процесу то процесу від
регламенту до регламенту І от я опинився
десь
абсолютно загубленим інтересом до своєї
професії
сповнений цікавістю до нього і от я став
дизайнером працює не по професії
До речі 80% людей з якими я працюю
спілкуюсь яких я наймаю теж працюють не
за спеціальністю яку вони отримують в
державній системі освіти
і виникає питання А чому так виходить що
людина потрапляє в заклад освіти Ну ніби
як це ще продовження дитинства в
дитинстві все цікаво в дитинстві це
відкривається перед тобою все життя а
виходить розчарована Людина яка не знає
куди себе подіяти яка списує який все це
не цікаво і вона просто здає екзамени
або там якісь там контрольні роботи для
того щоб отримати оцінку для того щоб
для того щоб її не виконали
то виникає питання як зробити так щоб От
ця людина виконала свої задачі і як нам
зробити так щоб ми розуміли ці задачі Ну
от Давайте подумаємо разом Які задачі у
нашого студента в системі профтехосвіти
існують
включити щось робити А ну спочатку Що
Яку проблему ми вирішуємо коли людина
приходить в систему профтехосвіти
аби налазить по під дворах А можна
уявити що вона хоче здобути професію яка
буде приносити її радість і задоволення
протягом її життя Окей тоді можна
спитати значить сказати що ця людина
знаходиться в точці А вона ще не в цій
професії а Наша задача провести її в
точку б вона в професії вона вміє і її
готові нейняти і тоді питання можна
поставити так як нам організувати все що
між цими двома точками для того щоб
людина туди реально дійшла і для того
щоб вона це зробила задоволенням і для
того щоб вона навчалась не для мами папи
не для Міністерства освіти не для
директора закладу не для свого вчителя А
що вони навчались для себе і якщо так
подивитись то свідчить дуже сильно
змінився от Ці діти які сьогодні є вони
ж відрізняються ну діти дорослі
Насправді те саме вони дуже сильно
відрізняються від от навіть мого
покоління вони вже народились вот з
таким телефоном
і в будь-який момент часу їх підручником
курує з Інстаграмом або з Тік током і як
правило це порівняння єдине на користь
підручника
ці люди мобільні вони хочуть
подорожувати вони піклуються про своє
ментальне здоров'я для них найважливіша
ідея бути щасливими і реалізуватись в
житті а не отримати гарну оцінку і
навіть не так добре заробляти
Окей Як це можна зробити Павло хочу
подискутувати
Я вибачаюсь я нічого не самі мені не
дали слово Питання в тому що я колеги це
право да от на стосовно телефона вот
реально ми маємо пам'ятати що телефон
Останній і ми вже з вами
в останньому вагоні якщо ми з вами не
станемо в першому вагоні буде пізно
діти дійсно вже народилися з цим
телефоном
Дякую І так перше що здається ми маємо
робити це поставити в центр процеса не
себе а дитину нашого учня і подумати про
те що їй треба їй треба потрапити в
точку б як нам зробити так щоб вона туди
хотіла потрапити А є такий спосіб він
конечно такий трохи зухвалений
спробувати розкрити її інтерес що її
справді мотивує навчатись
і це інтерес як правило Він же ж
позитивний тобто мене мотивує навчатись
і вас є певний мотивую навчатись не те
щоб вам хтось там догану зробить тому що
ви не навчаєтесь вам цікаво навчатись
тому що вам цікаве навчатись тому що є
щось у вас вабить тому що ви хочете щось
нове дізнатись тому що ви хочете
самореалізуватись і так далі як
реалізувати це під час навчання А в мене
навчаються до речі теж цікаві люди а це
мій заклад Я вважаю це такий вільний
профтех заклад а в ньому навчаються
дизайнери маркетологи програмісти і
всякі креативні люди які ще більш
критичний Які ще більш такий суворений
всіх дивиться і мотивувати їх Це перша
задача
значить як мотивувати
перша а здається для нас дуже важливим є
наблизити навчання до реального життя от
неможливо навчати поліцейського не на
кейсах які вирішують поліцейські
неможливо навчати дизайнера а
розповідаючи йому загальну теорію
мистецтва неможливо навчати маркетолога
так щоб йому було цікаво навчатись
розповідаючи достатньо далекі від нього
економічні теорії Наша задача наблизити
до людини предмет який ми викладаємо і
показати як ти можеш використати Це
сьогодні
А це викликає наступні питання А хто
може Таким чином подавати цей матеріал Я
знаю що сьогодні в системі профтехосвіти
існує таке обмеження що викладати
обов'язково мають люди з
педагогічну освіту якщо я не помиляюсь
принаймні існують певні квоти ми
переконались в тому що найкращі
викладачі які викладають у нас не мають
жодної педагогічного світу але вони
великі професіонали в своїй справі тому
що студент іде не за дипломом викладача
студент Іде за яскраву особистістю яка
може надихнути його яка може показати
власний приклад яка може показати Дивись
я вже досяг достатньо суттєвих
результатів своєї професії Я готовий
тебе провести тим же шляхом і тому ти
можеш мені вірити оце створення довіри
між студентами викладачами воно
надзвичайно надзвичайно важливим тому що
у студенти мають бути причини вірити
Чому ця людина може стати її провідником
тобто викладати На мою думку а професії
мають професіонали тобто Люди які
працюють і які самі були би затребувані
в цій сфері виникає наступна проблема
яку ми вирішили по-своєму Я не впевнений
що це універсальна порада Але тим не
менше Окей але ці люди вже затребувані у
своїй професії що вони будуть робити в
навчальному закладі
і ми ввели таке правило ми не беремо
професійних викладачів взагалі тобто у
нас немає жодної людини яка викладаю в
Full time чому Тому що ми хочемо щоб
вона мала актуальні знання в своїй
професії а оскільки професії Ви що
змінюються змінюються дизайн маркетинг
програмування стали варіння аграрна
сфера все зараз надзвичайно змінюється
все знаходиться під впливом технологій і
сьогодні аграрна сфера і вчора це
дві-дві дуже великі різниці сьогодні над
полями літають дрони склади такі
інізовані і ну це абсолютно інша сфери
життя існування Значить ми хочемо
залучити оцих людей які поєднують
викладання з роботою і мені здається що
це важливо щоб система дозволяла людині
одночасно працювати десь і викладати для
того щоб вона залишалась професійно в
своїй сфері і ще важливий момент що
викладач от як я коли вчився
а відповідальність насправді на учні
тому що він потім буде проживати своє
життя і воно буде якісним чи неякісним
щасливим нещасливим він реалізується чи
не реалізується тому дуже важливо
показати учню що відповідальність
знаходиться на твоєму боці І
знаєте це як якщо мама за мене весь час
буде готувати там суп то я ніколи не
почну готувати його сам або прибиратиму
кімнату Я ніколи не почну прибирати свою
кімнату тому що за мене все роблять
викладач має
немає бути викладачем який передав
знання і своєю голови в чужу Він має
бути провідником в професії Він має бути
ментором Він має подавати приклад Він
має давати Поради Він має
В деяких ситуаціях Він має порадити Як
тобі діяти в тій чи іншій ситуації і ще
дуже важливий момент що викладач - це
провідник по практичним завданням Я
переконаний в тому що
більшість часу учнів в закладі має
проводити над вирішенням практичних
задач якщо це майстер по дереву Він має
працювати з деревом якщо це дизайнер Він
має працювати з дизайном і працювати це
означає працювати от своїми руками тому
що в результаті у нього має з'явитися
портфоліо в результаті в результаті у
нього має з'явитися навички робіння
чогось і тоді ця система буде систему
яка виховує вільних людей які
зацікавлені в своїй роботі які можуть
виконати завдання які будуть поставлені
на роботі а не вчитись Коли вона прийде
і це є вільна система для вільної країни
яку ми хочемо побудувати дякую
надзвичайно
так друзі мої насправді уже починається
там церемонія нагородження і нам з вами
треба переміщатися Я дуже я надзвичайно
шкодую що мені не вдалося поставити у
мене було рівно одне запитання на вас
всіх і я думаю що
це дав Ні це не домашня робота ну
взагалі Да можна домашня робота Я хотів
щоб от У мене тут представники
метацентрів в мене тут керівники
закладів і мені хотілось щоб кожен із
них пішов звідси з якоюсь дуже простою і
дуже практичною порадою от ну от як Саша
нам на розказував да
е-е не чути Мене от майже чути тобто ну
наприклад коли Ніна
каже що от ми Ми провели там класні
навчання класні класні майстер-класи от
Я би хотів у нас же тут багато професій
на які професії це можна поширити як як
залучити як залучити цих виробників
роботодавців от з твоєї точки зору або
коли ви кажете короткі короткі програми
але тут методисти і викладачі Ви самі
кажете що це є спротив я як методистам
це продати в своїх закладах чого вони
мають захотіти ці короткострокові
програми робити або коли ви кажете про
це
формування кластерів цей е системний
підхід я я Як що корисного ну от що
корисно люди з вашого досвідуму можуть
взяти
до Павла точно так само Ну в тебе до
тебе насправді багато простіше було
питання Ти багато говорив про цінності і
мотивацією я би От так само хотів би щоб
ти кілька прикладів безпосередньо
мотивація розказав типу от я мотивую
отак беріть робіть це спробуйте у вас
теж вийде на жаль у нас на це все немає
часу Хай наші спікери виконають домашню
роботу і публікують десь статті якісь і
розкажуть Як вам як це робити я вам дуже
дякую за увагу Я дуже дякую Що ви не
заснули і що ви тут були щоб тому що
обід дійсно був нормальний це Дякую що
приїхали А ну і найважливіше оскільки Як
казав Дмитро Ми багато по поїздили по
регіонам я надзвичайно Дякую за вашу
роботу особливо центр південь е-е ви Ну
ви неймовірні те ну якби те в яких
умовах Ви працюєте і як вигрібаєте я ну
я не знаю ви ви Герої не з ким низьким
вам уклін
все дякую Там вас чекають подарунки